in the name of jesus anything
it would because it would be of an
antichrist spirit we break it right now
in the name of jesus every antichrist
spirit we break it right now
angels are being released right now
angels are being dispatched they're
coming here
in the name of jesus from south america
they're coming here
they're coming here they're coming here
they're being dispatched right now
angels are being released right now
angels are being dispatched they're
coming here
in the name of jesus from south america
they're coming here they're
[Music]
let there be that we would angels are
being released right now
angels are being dispatched they're
coming here in the name of jesus in
south america
they're coming here they're coming here
they're coming here
[Music]
victory victory victory in the quarters
of heaven
[Music]
[Laughter]
angels are being released right now
angels are being dispatched they're
coming here
in the name of jesus from south america
they're coming here
they're coming here they're coming here
angels are being released right now
angels are being dispatched they're
coming here
in the name of jesus from south america
they're coming here
they're coming here
[Music]
for every enemy that is aligned against
you let there be
that we would strike the ground for you
will give us victory god
i hear a sound of abundance of rain
let's go to the phones at 617-830-4750
um let's see let's first go to
uh oh you know who's on the phone donald
trump is holding on and last time
it was off the rails and that that
intrigues me i'm in an off the rails
sort of
what's going on number one i'm in love
that you're in love we're all in love
together
and when this happens is this like
parents is it siblings cousins what like
generation relative to you is
i've said that if ivanka weren't my
daughter perhaps i'd be dating her
hold on let's slow down because there's
a lot there let's really think it
[Music]
yeah she made through lot of money as a
model a tremendous amount and then she
went cold turkey and gave it all up
because she had to go to college because
i wanted
to go to college she goes to the best
college she goes to work
she got straight away let's take a step
back let's address a couple different
things it ultimately
the answer is really in you in the sense
of
what do you want your relationship to
look like
with these family members right because
i i could give you advice that would
[Music]
yeah i mean just work on being a normal
person my friend i'm gonna let you go
david you're born a certain way
and does it really change that much okay
i don't believe any of it that's all the
time i have for calls today sorry i
wasn't able to get to everybody but we
will take calls again
have with me david pakman he is a
progressive host
an executive producer of the nationally
syndicated radio and tv program
the david pacman show and i wanted to
talk to david pacman
he is a baby
david pacman he is
[Music]
can you remind the audience when you
talk about
being a beta male and being an alpha
male what what are we talking about here
there are males most men today yeah
male 1 they think and act like a woman
they are emotional
they are mentally off they have no logic
and that's a beta male they go along
with homosexuality hold on but holy whoa
whoa jesse well we gotta
that's a lot that's a lot hang on agree
with everything that's raw abortion they
think and act just like a woman a beta
male died
but another baby doesn't because he's a
logical thinking
and they're controlled by the darkness
of david pacman
he is a baby
david patman he is a baby
david pacman he is
david patman he is
[Music]
david you're not here to communicate i
really appreciate you coming out i'm
going to let you go it's a waste of time
to talk to you
we're not communicating you're actually
like because you're asking
bizarre questions you're acting like an
idiot and you're wasting my time
i appreciate that all right thank you
goodbye
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
is trump talking about massive dumps and
by the way extra points
if you can sample trump saying massive
dumps and me talking about it in a song
please do it
[Music]
dumps big massive dumps
[Music]
ducks dumps dumps
dumps
[Music]
donald trump multiple times
that it was massive dumps that led him
to lose the election
which is just dumps
dumps
[Music]
tremendous amounts of water where the
water rushes out to sea
[Music]
dumps
what is going on here what is going what
is going on here
it's just beyond parody massive dumps
cost them the election
what is going on here what is going what
is going on here
it's just beyond parody massive dumps
cost them the election
what is going on here what is going on
[Music]
gummy dumps dumpsters
dumps dumps
dumpsters
[Music]
dump big massive dumpsters
big massive dumps
all right welcome everybody we are going
to hear momentarily from
former president donald trump who will
be
speaking at cpac i will have highlights
from cpac
and there aren't many um and uh we will
look at a couple things but there it's
really it's there
there aren't really even highlights or
low lights it's sort of sort of been a
non-event in many ways
i didn't cover anything yesterday my
thought was
i had my second vaccine dose on friday i
was expecting to be quite ill
yesterday based on my first vaccine dose
and indeed i was had i wanted to stream
yesterday i would not have been able to
i was basically in bed with flu-like
symptoms all day
was able to get a ton of reading done
but
um i would not have been able to stream
yesterday but
what worked out is nothing happened
yesterday there was nothing to cover
yesterday at all just a very sad
low energy cpac and today
it will be wrapped up by a former
president donald trump and the question
is will he announce his candidacy for
president in 2024
the rumor has been the rumor has been
he may make that announcement today it
hasn't leaked one way or the other yet
although anthony scaramucci has
predicted that donald trump
will run for 2024 that doesn't mean he
will necessarily announce it today
but um we will see okay we will see
uh welcome to everybody there is so much
so much going on today i have new
songs to play for you i have clips from
cpac
i have unban requests i have an update
on the
toontoon channel takeover if you miss
the friday
show the friday stream i will catch you
up on
everything that is going on there is
just so much going on
um and let's let's dig right in with uh
some super chats first
let's see david i love you but your
stream intros are loony yeah they're
meant to be looney
that's okay bay photo says hey pacman
how are you almost time for cukes and
zuk z season by the way just out
watching the ads all the way through
help out the channel
probably although we have almost no uh
uh insight whatsoever into like if
someone watches part of an ad versus all
of an
ad do we get more i have no idea i have
no idea i appreciate everyone's support
regardless
excuse me just choked on my own saliva
christian says
over or under two minutes before trump
says he really won the election i think
under two minutes
i already saw one report saying that
trump's entire speech is basically going
to be just rehashing the big lie
the voter fraud claims i think it'll be
under two minutes
people in the chat let me know what you
think but i think there's no way trump
goes two minutes without claiming he won
yeah people are saying will it be under
20 seconds never mind two minutes
i agree i think it's definitely under
under 20 minutes
now let me issue a couple of disclaimers
because i'm seeing this in twitch and
youtube chat
for all of the losers continuing to say
david you won't cover the andrew cuomo
scandal because you
are a you know kind of pick your own
adventure shill
democratic tool whatever
we've now covered it multiple times i
laid out all four
aspects of the scandal on the thursday
show
i'm not a democrat i don't care if
andrew cuomo goes down in flames if
that's what should happen
i've reported on it i said do every
investigation understand everything
that's going on guys come on
come on we don't have time for that we
just don't have time i've already
covered it
and we will continue to cover it and by
the way tomorrow
i'm going to be going after joe biden on
the syria bombing
i just if you're looking for channels
that are partisan democratic channels
this isn't it
i've never been a democrat i don't care
about politicians as heroes or deities
or anything like that
this is the wrong channel if you're
looking for that
okay i don't care about partisanship or
any of that stuff yes very edgy day
thank you
okay other super chats um
president reject trump he will announce
so he can raise
funds that may be if you haven't already
do you plan to address the shape of the
cpac stage uh
maybe maybe david i love your content so
does my mom it's her birthday it would
make her day if you wished mary a happy
birthday yes
penn sylvester says it is mary's
birthday i don't know if it's mary
sylvester
mary happy birthday i'm so glad for you
to be joining us today
and i hope it is a great birthday david
keep in mind if you want peppers this
season you need to get
seeds ready now now now i buy seedlings
i am not a good enough gardener to to
grow from seed
i did grow my cukes from seed last year
but it was just by chance i go with
seedlings so i've still got a little
while
i know it's very beta i should be
growing from seed but
what can i do what song will trump walk
out to maybe that
country song about being an american i
don't know
florida 2022 is a lost cause despite
nothing
about covid ron desantis despite doing
nothing about covid ron desantis has 54
approval it's insane it's insane
trump needs to be taken out before he
runs in 2024. i think you mean
politically if you mean violence
then the answer is no we do not advocate
for physical violence on this program
most underrated ground garden fruit
obviously it's ground
cherries they grow perfectly on the east
coast you'll be amazed at the amount of
fruit you get
i've heard ground cherries are a great
thing to grow
is there a location to access all of the
remixes there is not
also trump is too narcissistic to
support anyone other than himself so he
will run again unless it's one of his
kids
um okay
david is milking trump ratings guys i i
cover everything that goes on i cover
press briefings i cover biden speeches
vaccine events today trump is speaking
so i'm covering it
what do you want me to do um okay
question about ecuador i'm not
keeping up with that right now and will
the republican party end up splitting
i've covered that extensively on the
youtube channel so i won't dig into that
right now
okay let me get to a few things number
one
there is nothing more important than
making sure every one of our
website supporters gets a thank you so i
want to say thanks to
samuel sulliman samuel soliman has just
signed up
ryan brooks is a new member and dexyco
has just signed up at joinedpakman.com
putting us at three
i also want to say thanks to five people
who signed up via twitch including
mutiny who has now been a twitch sub for
15 months which is
absolutely wild let's go to a few
moments from
cpac let me see where do i have them
here
oh ted cruz appeared to suffer a manic
episode
during his speech here i'll have a full
review on tomorrow's show
here are the last seven seconds where
ted cruz goes full mania
and he um this is a u.s senator if you
can imagine that
in the immortal words of william wallace
freedom
[Applause]
in the immortal words of william wallace
freedom so a complete uh just a manic
episode by cruz
and there was one other one where he was
starting to lose it
i think it was i think it was this one
we can have herd immunity everywhere
and we're gonna wear masks for the next
300 years
and by the way not just one mask two
three four
you can't have too many masks
how much virtue do you want a signal
this is just dumb
just a terrible terrible person ted cruz
so there's that
and then oh oh this is gold i hope you
everybody's sitting down
for this and get the kids out of the
room as many of you know oh hold on i
think i'm getting a message there's
something wrong with the stream
oh no okay um okay so listen to this
throughout cpac there have been panels
pushing two different things one
uh non-science-based coveted claims
like what we just saw non-science-based
coveted claims
and non non-fact-based
election claims about the election was
stolen and all this different stuff
right side broadcasting cut away from
one of the various
weaponized disinformation segments to
issue
the funniest disclaimer about
researching for yourself stuff about the
election and talking to doctors before
following any
of the advice of the speakers check out
this
hilarious disclaimer that right side
broadcasting
cut away from during cpac this is
amazing
three different states forty two
thousand votes forty five thousand
something like that and we would have
had an electoral college uh vote of 269
to 269. there's a lot of sensitive
topics
being talked about right now we want
everyone to do your own research
in regards to what they're talking about
in this discussion right
this is called we don't want to get sued
now anything with the election or
anything
like that so uh it's important to do
your own research i know there's several
outlets here that are able to
completely uh broadcast all of this
content
right for you with any disclaimer at all
but unfortunately here at right side
broadcasting we must
he's he's upset he has to issue a
disclaimer but for legal reasons he does
jump in here and put a small disclosure
that
we want you to do your own research and
it's very important that we do that yeah
absolutely just quickly although we are
broadcasting these speakers we want to
provide you with that
it does not mean that we necessarily
believe or support
all of their beliefs of every single
speak speaker talking today so make sure
that you
research everything you talk to your
healthcare position physicians whether
it's
medical information they're really upset
they can't just broadcast the lies with
no disclaimer so they're broadcasting
them with a disclaimer
and if it's election related just look
it up
and look everything up and we are just
not endorsing any speakers for the event
again we are simply broadcasting these
speakers right so there's that and then
here's the last thing
now i don't want to make fun of anybody
i'm sure that this young lady is very
very nice
but there was one of the strangest
national anthem performances i've seen
i'm without making fun of anybody i
wonder about how this individual was
chosen to deliver the national anthem
this was just unusual
[Music]
all i want to say is if democrats had an
event and this was the singer the right
would be saying this is disrespectful to
the anthem
okay totally respectfully okay we
at the twilight's last gleaming
whose broad stripes and
bright stars
[Music]
were so gallantly
[Music]
[Music]
while still there
oh say doesn't that star
spangled then yet
wave
for the land of the freeze
[Music]
so not exactly whitney at the super bowl
but i mean i'm sure this young lady is
really nice but if if democrats did this
the right would say this is
disrespectful to the anthem and
disrespectful to the flag
okay i mean it is what it is i don't
know what else to say but so that was
that was the national anthem at cpac so
needless to say cpac not going
great so far not going great so far i
think is all that we can say
and then it will be wrapped today with a
speech
from uh donald trump in about a half
hour
or so all right so that is that
let me get caught up here i want to make
sure everybody who's supporting the
stream gets a thank you
big thank you to dylan keller as well as
matt
colson i want to say thanks to wayne
adams as well
three new members who signed up at
joinpackman.com
today is the last day of february
february so far
unfortunately our worst month from the
standpoint of new members in nine months
so i would love it if you grabbed a
membership at joinpakman.com the coupon
code better21 is available
i also want to say thank you to the 12
folks
that grabbed subscriptions via twitch
putting us
at 23. thanks very much okay
um do you guys want i have two i'm gonna
do both of these things you let me know
which you want next
either an update on the toontoon youtube
channel
or an update on haiku hillbilly
song parodies or oh unban requests i
have one on band requests which i'll do
a little bit later in the meantime i'm
gonna read a few super chats
uh will when will dictator cult leader
trump be held accountable
sadly i don't know that he ever will the
anthem made me almost lose my mind i
haven't laughed like that in a year
i know david you don't get it that was a
reharmonized fusion jazz arrangement of
the anthem if you were more intelligent
you would realize
you know what it sort of reminded me of
yoko ono
once did yoko ono
once did a sort of avant-garde
this is like two avant-garde even for me
check this out the national anthem
was basically it was the national
anthem version of this okay
by the way look at the closed captions
okay anyway that was the uh the national
anthem at cpac was basically
it was taking the national anthem and
overlaying a layer of that type of
avant-garde stuff onto it
and that's what we ended up with okay
good as a musician i can tell you my
ears are bleeding
all right sit down with james o'brien of
lbc
pick a key and sing it okay so a lot of
stuff about um
a lot of stuff about the national anthem
okay let's go
first to uh song parodies
so on friday i introduced to you guys
a new voicemail caller who we are
calling
either the haiku hillbilly or mark twang
this was the voicemail that i presented
to you on friday
i'll tell you one thing boy trump
is more man than you'll ever be
trump is more american than you'll ever
be
trump has got more money than you'll
ever have
[Music]
you are bought and paid for
joe [ __ ] biden
so i received three beautiful
song parodies okay and i put out a call
i said any of the people that like to
remix songs get in touch if you want
that original file
we want remixes i have three to present
for you today
i have haiku hullabaloo by the
mar-a-lago
mixer i have the haiku hillbilly master
by private jet lag
and then i also have haiku hillbilly by
steven montez
okay these are the three submissions so
far let's get right into it
all very different all right all right
well hello
how are we doing hey guys listen listen
to this you guys have to listen to this
i'll tell you one thing boy
trump is more man than you'll ever be
trump is more american than you'll ever
be
trump has got more money than you'll
ever have
okay you are bought and paid for
joe [ __ ] fine
uh-oh what do you guys think what do we
what do we need uh
what do we need as a nickname for that
gentleman
brbq that's not bad
mike pillow
[Music]
swole cheeto
the wrestler where is hunter
you are blocked and paid for
joe [ __ ] fine that is insane
all right so that's that's haiku hollow
blue by the mar-a-lago mixer
okay this is haiku hillbilly master by
private jet lag
trump is more man than you'll ever be
more american than you will ever be
it's got more money than you'll ever
have
this one builds
[Music]
okay so i think you guys get that one
and then lastly this one is by stephen
montez i think this one
my prediction is people might like this
one the best okay
i'll tell you one thing boy
trump is more man than you'll ever be
haiku hillbilly i'm glad you brought
this up
trump is more american than you'll ever
be
hillbilly haiku very very well said
trump has got more money than you'll
ever have
haiku hillbilly it's almost like a
poetry in a sense
you are bought and paid for
most of this stuff is bottom feeding
trash
hillbilly haiku is more man
than you'll ever be all right so i guess
it seems like people are actually liking
the second one the best
[Music]
what do you guys think
[Music]
all right so anyway those are the three
submissions i got we'll close
that out and that and that uh okay
good so if any if anybody else wants to
send in submissions you can get in touch
via email i'll get you the original uh
voicemail track and you can
you can submit stuff all right very very
exciting thank you so much
let me say thank you to lee beltran who
just signed up at joinedpakman.com also
want to say thanks to ian duncan
andrew mckinney just grabbed a
membership at joinpacman.com
cairo richards is a new member and you
know what just because we're counting
everything
jinsky robinson just pledged via patreon
we're gonna count everything just
because we need it we need all the
numbers we can get
um also big thank you to the nine folks
who just grabbed twitch subs including
cloud from fifi insert clever username
tcp the ninja miravis pants just gifted
five
subs which is extremely powerful
putting us at 37.
i do have one unban request to
adjudicate let's do that twitch has a
mechanism where if you get banned and
you want to appeal the ban you can do so
uh i am going to convene with my gavel
we are convening as a a court of uh
unbanned requests we are going to review
an
unban request from a user named doc
c8383
who joined today and sent the following
messages
can't wait for a real president to speak
bisden can't remember where he is half
the time
it is a hoax all commies must hang got
to happen
sooner or later trump will win 2024
ah the left doing lefty things like
banning people
magga no magga it's revenge i just got
out of church it's nice to be around
people
no mask no fake girls no crying little
[ __ ]
god is good they were subsequently
banned
their unbanned request is f you david
you fake ass [ __ ] this is a very
uh easy one for me to adjudicate this is
an
individual whose presence in our streams
is toxic
destructive and i am hereby
denying the unbanned request it has been
made a permanent ban
and this court has ruled and that is it
uh and that is the only unbanned request
that i had today
to look at that isn't that's an easy
permaban
that's not even one that i have to think
too much about it's just so
so uh so vile and toxic okay
let me get to a few other super chats
danny says how do i watch the david
pakman show live um
there's the show was recorded in the
afternoon
in the early afternoon and published in
the late afternoon there's no way to do
it live
fujikara says short pacman february
membership
long on tune tune all right let me
address the toontoon stuff
okay this is one of the coolest things i
would argue that we've we've ever done
that you guys have ever done that the
community has ever done
on friday i mentioned that as i've been
shouting out different youtube channels
that i watched
i mentioned that there's a friend of
mine
um an ex-co-worker of my girlfriends
who started a thai cooking
youtube channel which i think is is
fantastic
and at the time that i mentioned him on
friday
he had 276 youtube subscribers
i thought i'll mention it maybe he'll
pick up a couple hundred subscribers
he picked up 3 000 subscribers from me
mentioning it
okay this is the toontoon channel he is
now
up to 3850 subscribers we
made this channel go uh
about 15x within a few hours
the absolute funniest thing about this
is you now go into the videos
first of all we were thanked in one of
the videos check this out
first i want to give a big shout out to
the david pakman show for featuring my
channel on his last live stream
i'm so grateful for your support and the
love from your amazing community
by the way my community is more
respectful and polite
to him than to me we were just briefly
exchanging messages
he's like your community's fantastic
they're so supportive i said
my commuter they hate me they seem to
like you better than they like me half
the people in my community hate me
uh but in any case you look at the um
you look at the comments they're all
pacman comments
david pakman sent me continue to hold
toontoon stock everyone it's going to
the moon
i've been subscribed to david pakman's
show i'm here because of david pakman
anyone here from sam cedar didn't think
so
only david pakman makes dreams comes
true so much love brother coming from
the david pakman show as soon as david
said thai food i was sold
pacman sent me and you know what i don't
regret holding
yes david sent me hi here from the david
pakman show
thank you for dave thank you to david we
have
blown up this channel and it is
happening again
look at this look at this my mere
mention
of the toontoon channel is making it
explode
i think we could get this to 5 000
subscribers i'm just going to post
the link just once here posting it in
twitch chat
and then uh
posting it in youtube chat as well
we have single-handedly turned around
this channel
it's fantastic 4 000 now
almost 4 100
unbelievable and i guess i must be doing
something wrong because all my fault
half my followers hate me
but all my followers love the toontoon
channel
so um all very exciting stuff yeah why
stop at 5 000 let's just keep it going
and going and going
so anyway really exciting stuff but i
appreciate everybody who is now
following the toontoon channel
and a lot of really oh and by the way by
special request
i believe he will soon be doing a tom
yum
soup video tom yum one of my absolutely
favorite favorite favorite soups so
really exciting
that's probably that's probably enough
as far as toontune goes oh and the other
really funny thing is
i didn't realize this i this isn't a
flex but
we get like you know one to two thousand
new subscribers a day so if i had my
phone dinging every time i got a new
subscriber
i couldn't get anything done toontune
still had individual notifications
turned on
so he got about 3 000 phone
notifications during work
on friday if you can ima i mean it's
just it's crazy
it's absolutely crazy to imagine that
all right
so things are very exciting and we'll
check back in on that
a little bit later as we get closer and
closer to the uh
to the donald trump speech okay big
thank you to jessica
morgan as well as valerie crumley and
nathan bloom who just signed up at
joinpacman.com putting us at 40
for the day let me get to some super
chats i know that there are people
angry with me that i'm not reading super
super chat so let's look at it david
when will i wear
judicial robes and a powdered wig when i
adjudicate
the unbanned request maybe david will
you ever
tour the show live or an upcoming
talking tour you know
anna casparian from the young turks and
i were set to do
a a medium-sized cities tour
and then covet hit and it all got
canceled
i would love to put something back
together i would once
we are beyond we once we are beyond it
jay's review says i noticed sam cedar
tends to discuss right-wing grifters
like dave rubin a lot but you don't do
it as often
is that an intentional choice on your
end i mean
i don't know it's not i'm not avoiding
discussing grifters
i just find that it's not that
interesting to me i mean yes there's
grifters all over the place
enlightened centrists and people who had
political awakenings
i don't know i don't find it to be the
most interesting topic
i wonder if the religious conservatives
can see the omega level irony in the
golden calf
i mean golden trump statue they probably
can't
other super chats it seems dictatorial
of you david
what does abrasive says i think the
discount code is broken is it because of
huge dumps of new subscribers i don't
think so people are using the new
discount code
everybody's using the code um
nathan just used the code jessica just
used the code
lee used the code everybody's using the
code it seems to be working fine
i wonder if the religious conserve oh
okay i already that's a duplicate
hey there i want you to say hi lorenska
my daughter is watching
thank you ahmad yes hi to lorenzka glad
families are watching today very
very family-friendly show today joseph
wants to know why the stage is shaped as
the odle rune i don't know i quite
frankly don't know
that may be legit that that that may may
not be
i don't know can i get a shout out to my
girlfriend priscilla who is now a fan of
yours we have gotten so close because of
you that's a beautiful story
messiah francois gets a shout out to
priscilla
thanks priscilla very much appreciate it
if you were just
joining you have not missed the trump
speech we're about 12 minutes from the
trump speech
let's check in on what's happening now
live at cpac
we are standing by for the trump speech
looks like it like final preparations
are taking place
nobody's late oh did we get to 5k on
toontoon
not quite no not quite there are people
predicting 5k
you know anybody who shorted toontune
stock is going to be sadly disappointed
when we hit
5k and then we're going to 10k and then
who knows where we're going
um no i think it's going to continue
i think it will very very much continue
all right very good standing by for
donald trump
oh my god they're now doing a tribute to
rush limbaugh you can imagine
so that's that's happening next amazing
okay let me get to a couple of other
things oh covid cases
yes people have asked about coveted
cases so
there was a slight if we look at the
average of cases
over the last seven days you will see
that there was this
leveling off this plateau my belief
is that this is not a genuine leveling
off i think that in this period right
here
because of the storms a lot of testing
was delayed
i think this decline was larger than
real
and now as testing is getting caught up
after the storms
it looks as though it's leveling
leveling off i think the the quote
real numbers are probably just a
continued but slower decline
i think this next 10 days it'll continue
going down
same thing as far as deaths are
concerned
there was this little uptick here and
then it's going back down
i i think these are basically artifacts
of storms
and i think we are going to continue on
the way down
vaccination numbers are continuing to
improve
and it we're looking at over 100 million
doses delivered just in march alone
forget about 100 million in 100 days
we're looking at 100 million doses
delivered in march alone
um and i'm expecting the numbers to
continue improving so no i don't think
there's really a reversal i do think
there's a possibility
um i do think there's a possible wow a
lot of crazy stuff going on now
i do think there's a possibility that we
see um
an uptick later on but i think for now
we're going to continue going down
vaccines are looking good people who
missed the beginning of the stream i was
sick with a fever headache
chills body aches yesterday i had my
second dose on friday
couldn't have streamed even if i wanted
to yesterday
all right let's get to some other twitch
messages
km clay zoo has subscribed and says
fewer trump rally
rallies contributed to covid declined
that maybe
remy lebro says nine months david i got
my second
fiser shot on friday no symptoms
other than a sore arm did your second
dose go well oh i just addressed that it
went very well
i feel uh like i've developed antibodies
but i was sick in bed yesterday
it's been an amazing 11 months with
david's help says kalinas who subscribed
for 11 months
and pedro corleone says it's been four
months already yes
thanks guys uh that's an additional
10 twitch subscribers putting us at 50.
it's a weird noise and also want to say
thank you to
daniel johnson for subscribing at
joinpakman.com
greg crickshank has subscribed on my
website
heath givens i wonder if that's the
heath givens i know that's interesting
if it's heath from florida heath givens
has subscribed
and josh porter has subscribed that's
54.
uh love it very much appreciate it as we
stand by for trump
gareth says just sent a blank message
for a fiver surely you can give gareth
from
bar malden in london a shout the only
place to be when trump talks is nonsense
i've heard actually people have told me
david i was at a london
pub and they were playing your live
stream
i would love either video or images of
that
if you are at any pub particularly in
london
um and people are watching the stream
get us the video get us the pictures
that would be a cool thing
to uh to put up but yes shout out to
gareth from bar malden
grant says hey david beautiful bathers
in the house do you think it will be
kamala
versus trump in 2024 no idea whatsoever
i'm focused in on 2022 for the time
being
gen x's salutations from manchester uk
super guy says will we be back to normal
by august
let's do everything we can in march
let's focus on march
and see where we are on april 1st how
come reporters shout and yell over each
other to ask questions at press
conferences seems unproductive
not at press briefings at press
briefings gensake calls on people
but yes sometimes with biden people yell
questions it's not particularly
productive
have i seen trump's utterly deathly and
ghoulish picture with ken paxton on
twitter
also got on the hang up i love you
okay i don't know about that let's do a
search for that picture
trump ken paxton
photos
well trump does look weird wow that's
interesting
he looks uh he looks
almost like gaunt in a weird way like
he's still heavy
but his face does look gaunt it's it's
strange
well we'll see what he's looking like
now momentarily as we stand by for
donald trump just moments away from
donald trump's speech
shea says to everyone wondering how
david was able to get a vaccine his
medical history is
not your business know that i've already
said
oh and by the way not only have i said
about this uh let me see here vaccine
waiting list somebody sent me
uh oh damn it i wanted to promote this
there's a website where you can
basically put your name on it
and then if there's leftover vaccines
before the the long and short of it is
there's vaccines going in the trash in a
lot of places
a lot a lot of places and either
if you know someone or if some place
maintains a list or some people are just
showing up and hanging out outside
when they get a vial with five doses
open
and they get to the end of the day those
are gonna go bad if they're not used
within five
six hours it's an opportunity for
whoever's around to get a dose
and uh that is that is essentially what
what is going on
and um that would be something to look
at there's a website where you can
register for that
yeah i got a trash vaccine exactly hey
david watching from work in littleton
massachusetts i predict trump will say
he was treated unfairly and the election
was stolen every two to three minutes
and he will bring up windmills at least
once i think he will likely bring up
windmills yeah
greetings from canada really enjoy your
content i love it when you put your
hands to your face in surprise
that's a shocking shocking message
what is the website i'm sorry i can't
find it
let me see here hold on uh audience
emails vaccines
searching for vaccines is going to find
people who mostly
are sending me anti-vaxx insanity
extra doses oh oh oh here it is hold on
okay now i'm gonna i'm gonna paste the
link i don't know if this goes for the
entire country
or not this is the website that was sent
to me h-i-d-r-b.com
don't let covet vaccinations go to waste
381 000 sign ups
dr b provides a standby list that
connects patients needing the vaccine
with providers
needing to administer vaccines before
they expire
patients should first attempt to sign up
for the vaccine directly
dr b is an independent public benefit
corporation
i don't know what on earth this is okay
so i'm just putting it out there like i
hope this isn't
bad or a scam of any kind but this is
the website that was sent to me
h-i-d-d-h-i-d-r-b.com
buyer beware your own mileage may vary
if i click i want it you put in your
number
please check it out okay someone can
figure it out
and let me know whether that's that's
legit i have no idea who dr b
is like literally no idea that's just
something that was sent to me
it says big corporations support it i
don't know if that's good or bad
i don't know if that means it's legit
pubs are closed in the uk we're on
lockdown oh okay
your local walmart is doing this you
call to be put on the waiting list for
leftover shots
got my shot yesterday from the leftover
pile jenks pronounced
jenks okay
very good appreciate that
i want to say thank you to luis baeza
for signing up at joinedpakman.com and
christopher cebaldi
thanks guys i really do appreciate the
support
as we stand by for donald trump let's
listen thank you
you're just the best my family is just
they're still on the rush limbaugh
tribute
tribute shout out to the viewer from
littleton mass i'm from
lunenburg mass david i heard super
pro-life people say they weren't going
to take it because it uses stuff from
aborted fetuses i can't find anything
about it
i i don't know anything about that
either
couldn't uh couldn't advise you on that
my friend
david what is the best way to support
your work it's it's the website listen
we'll take everything but the truth is
like all of these other platforms we
love these platforms youtube twitch etc
they all are taking big big slices when
you sign up on my website
we pay two percent for swiping credit
cards and we keep the rest
it's that's the highest percentage of
anything we'll take it all
you know beggars can't be choosers but
by all means that is that is the
the where we keep the most
trump's arm is covered in band-aids oh i
didn't notice that hold on a second
i don't see any oh his there looks like
there's a band-aid
on his finger i don't see any other oh
this is a band-aid oh yeah that's weird
hmm that is strange
yeah i don't know what to make of that
look at this preparing for trump
apparently
my trump cpac parley is he will trash
liz cheney say the election was a fraud
and he is running for president what are
yours david
i'm not taking i'm not making any
guesses at all
not a mask in sight even though oh well
there's a mask
even though they've asked masks to be
worn here's one other mask
we're getting very close here
you wish you were there guys to take it
all in
just kidding hey david love from canada
and australia hoping to visit the us for
the first time in years in 22
i vowed never to visit while trump is
president i understand that a lot of
people
sharing that and that led to a
significant decline
in tourism dollars to the u.s under
trump
thank you to symbolic gamer who says i
heard a doctor was punished for giving
out soon to be expired
doses i did not hear that but anything
is certainly possible
thanks also to wrote rhodagi
and trichilleric and a few other people
who signed up via twitch putting us at
62.
we are very close to a speech from trump
anticipating a lot of insanity
unclear if he will announce that he's
running
in 2024 that is the big rumor
the theme of this cpac america
uncanceled
i don't know make of it what you will
it's certainly odd
big thank you to johnny herrera as well
as nick smith for signing up at
joinpackman.com
uh oh people are asking me to check the
toontoon channel let's see where we did
we breach five thousand
tell me we breached five thousand
we didn't i think we can do it guys
this is a youtube channel that we
single-handedly brought
from 276 subscribers on friday to 3500
thai cooking friend of vine runs this
channel runs his channel it's fantastic
grows his own kefir lime leaves
an unbelievable channel
user oh green tea is the problem it's a
different username
uh i don't think it is
no this is this is the right this is the
this is the channel
4950 49 this is this is the right
channel guys
i don't why i don't know why people are
telling me this is the wrong one and
we are so close i'm going to paste the
link in twitch chat
and youtube chat a couple of times i
think we're about to break 5000 on
toontoon and there it is
5 000 this channel had 276
subs just 48 hours ago
we did it america we did it five
thousand fifty one hundred
this is absolutely crazy and we were
thanked by the way if people miss this
i wanna give a big shout out to the
david pakman show for featuring my
channel on his last live stream
i'm so grateful for your support and the
love from your amazing community
you guys welcome back unbelievable an
unbelievable turn of events and
uh a lot happening so anyway that's that
we i know
wow 53 it's going vertical
this is like that day bitcoin went crazy
it's like the game stock
situation crazy i think this channel is
going to do really well
i'm glad i got in on the ground floor
all right we are standing by for donald
trump coming up very very soon
very soon cdc just approved the jnj
vaccine
yes will trump announce he is subscribed
to toontoon
that matt can you imagine
david have you ever been to nantasket
beach in hull massachusetts
never never ever ever
hey david huge fan i spent time in
buenos aires argentina met my esposa in
medellin
colombia on a fulbright wanted to let
people know i use this account to help
people with
essays for international grants thank
you
brian baron gaffner says i look forward
to seeing trump take responsibility
and talk about the lessons he learned
along the way
yeah well i hope you're not holding your
breath on that
cell lines derived from fetal tissue are
often used in lab experiments to help
develop vaccines in almost all cases
not in manufacturing there it is
very important and very well said if
covet never happened would trump have
won
possibly but here's the here's the gimme
if trump had merely handled covid like a
normal person he would have easily won
if trump had just stood aside and said
here's what the doctors say to do let's
do it we're making maga masks
wear them it's patriotic trump would be
president right now there's no doubt
about it
alex says i don't know why but i'm super
excited about his speech miss that trump
insanity
very good david your shameless pump and
dump scheme
on tune is becoming more apparent by the
day the fec
is watching yeah
no i mean listen if you're if you're the
sec
and you see numbers like this i can
understand why you would start an
investigation
i can absolutely understand that there's
no doubt about that
let's listen in and see what's happening
here
[Music]
getting ready uh there's a big build up
here to a uh it will be a hugely defiant
speech here
by uh by donald trump thank you to
karena karena for signing up at
joinpackman.com
thanks to laurie hart
for signing up big thank you to nathan
kasmanov as well as talissa dean
thanks so much to all of you that puts
us at 68.
oh my god look at this video you have to
see this
rigged election
[Music]
why is there so much korean oh k
c pack korea what the hell
is there some kind of like trumpian
korea movement i know that there's a
japanese
korea a japanese trump movement i don't
know what that's about
really weird just bizarre
do you think the odell rune stage layout
was intentional i really don't know
i really don't know
um cpac where trump gives a ted talk on
insurrections yeah
can you become my press secretary when i
become potus absolutely
absolutely i mean i i should know a
little bit about your positions first
but uh but i think so
i think so david why do you think left
wingers are honest and very good at
informing people
well right wingers use misinformation
and what about isms
that's a bit too black and white for me
juni
but i've explained the differences in
why we see
one type of messaging versus another
from left and right
would i consider anti-vaxx a covert
racist
method which group is most affected by
covid seems the most right-wing message
possible
i'm not sure about that i haven't
thought about that in those terms
david thoughts on pokemon legends arcus
game i don't know anything about that
i don't know a thing about that
you know one of the things i did do this
weekend this is big gaming news
be as many of you know i was down
yesterday with my second vaccine dose i
had
fever chills hot cold
achy headache eye pressure
sore i had the full boat i installed one
of my favorite childhood video games
growing up the game is
xcom ufo defense i had a great time
playing it great great time playing it
what is going on back here with my
the other day my mallet actually broke
my little clip for my earpiece i'm still
waiting on one to be shipped to me from
bh photo video
there we go david what happened to the
end of hassan's stream yesterday i
have no idea did something happen people
would have to tell me
hassan was maulding yeah i don't know i
have no idea what happened with the sun
david if you die at cpac do you die in
real life i think so
what is your favorite eric the actor
moment this is a howard stern reference
eric the actor sadly we lost
eric the actor some years ago it feels
like yesterday but i think it was years
ago
one of my favorite eric the actor
moments was
i think when he left a voicemail to
johnny frato
saying you know what to do seemingly put
putting a hit on someone
i don't remember who it was even on uh
but
that's probably my favorite moment
also when he would ask really specific
questions of wrestlers i liked that too
do they realize the campaign is over
maga hats
i don't think a lot of these people
realize it and in fact it may not be
over because trump may announce 2024 run
moments from now hey david here in
brazil we'll try to get rid of bolsonaro
but i'm already relieved that his
american counterpart is gone
love your show well said
well said there are a lot of christian
korean conservatives in the u.s i grew
up near a lot of them
yeah you know i've read many books about
um
korean refugees who escape north korea
and often they will become evangelical
christians they get sucked in by
evangelical christianity
david have you ever been to northern
ireland or ireland no
my only visit to ireland has been
about three hours at dublin airport uh
on a stopover i flew air lingus
uh really cunning airline in fact what
they do by setting up these routes where
it's just the most convenient thing
and some people extend their stop over
for several days i was flying home
from palma de machorica or majorca as
some people who are not argentinian
would
say to the u.s and i stopped over in
dublin
and i uh i actually had a great smoked
salmon sandwich there the smoked salmon
was
tremendous tremendous smoked salmon and
uh it was good that's the only time i've
flown air lingus and the only time i've
been in ireland
okay other super chats how do i get a
vaccine i've explained it like a hundred
times already so i'm gonna skip over
that what will it say on trump's lectern
that i don't know you would like xcom
enemy within if you like the older
x-coms
here's my question i actually bought a
package of all the x-coms on steam
are the newer x-coms also turn based
strategy or is it a different thing
altogether
because i like the turn-based nature of
the old x-com games
they are turn-based okay but they're
hugely different
i might try it i might try i own all of
them
yeah i'm gonna check that out david if
you don't start streaming yourself
playing video games i will blow up my
pets with tnt don't do that ryan that
would be really sad
uh welcome to everybody who's just
joining us we are standing
by for former president donald trump's
first
speech uh since leaving
the white house we believe he may
announce a 2024 run this was already
scheduled to start 10 minutes ago from
the looks of it it could be hours
until it starts again i have no idea how
long it's going to be
this is a really effective way to wear a
mask right here see this guy right here
that's a super effective strategy that
does a lot for everybody around you
really considerate way to wear the mask
um okay
if you were just joining us i stream
during the week
so if you're watching on twitch i would
love it if you
followed me if you're watching on
youtube i would love it if you
subscribed to the channel
and if you're watching on facebook i
would love it if you hit that like
button
if you want to do a little something
extra
you can go to joinpakman.com and grab a
membership
the coupon code better21 saves you
massively and i want to say thanks to
lauren
smith who just signed up at
joinpackman.com
putting us at 69 out of 100
new members and twitch subs today
thanks to some great people over on
twitch including
sea world's first trans orca that's a
weird name
also admiral bones and others
that's six additional subscribers via
twitch putting us at 75
i heard a crazy rumor the other day and
i mentioned this and nobody in the chat
could tell me if this was true
i heard a rumor that in any given live
stream
90 of people in the the stream
who have an amazon prime account have
not used their twitch prime sub like
it's just
hanging there could that possibly be
true 90 percent does anybody know
nobody knows
it might be somebody says okay
90 seems high see i think the thing is a
lot of people don't even know what
twitch prime is
a lot of people have amazon prime and
they just don't know that with amazon
prime you can
link it to twitch and you have a free
twitch prime sub to support a channel
um yeah i don't know i mean 90
does seem high it seems high but it
wouldn't be shocking
look at what's going on it looks like
they've put a stage together and now
they're taking it apart
the tutorial for xcom eu perma-kills
three-quarters of your squad to prepare
you for the experience
wow david i love the show what kind of
computer is your gaming computer
i don't even know it's a dell
off-the-shelf dell
david what if it's trump biden again in
2024
all right uh-oh matt schlapp let's see
what he's saying uh since we're in
florida it's nice and air-conditioned in
here because
the one thing i always know about my
floridian wife is they love that air
conditioning
i like your sign ma'am that's a very
pretty flag back there
uh and in the meantime for a few moments
i
wanted to remind you all that it's not
just the people in this room
who are watching and listening to this
content
obviously people from all over america
if social media
is allowing it to happen i hope you're
all getting your feeds
but you know who else is watching
the whole world
the whole world is looking at america
and saying
what the hell is going on embrace
socialism or fight back
there's no socialist in government and
so we're going to give you a little
indicator of how cpac and the american
conservative movement
is working with freedom loving people
please please watch
really glitchy feed let's switch feeds
oh this one's not even showing anything
let's see
guess what today's cpac
is the biggest and best we've ever seen
matt schlapp introducing a video of matt
schlapp
wow um i don't even really like being on
right side broadcasting let's see where
we could go instead maybe we'll be here
um maybe we'll just keep it here for the
time being and hope it smooths out
all right we're we're hoping for uh
we're hoping for for trump very soon
see this is what i'm talking about
dozens of people in twitch are saying
they didn't even know what
what uh twitch prime was so it it might
be that 90
of people don't have any idea how that
whole thing all works
okay other super chats super chat from
sabrina and ace
ms smith says favorite tweet today sv
date says trump is now late for his own
party
what else did he has going on today just
a small giggle
yeah trump's late to everything turns
out humans can survive
on a diet of red meat i i assume you
mean metaphorical red meat right
oh my god look at glenn beck what
happened to his physical appearance
looks i barely recognized him there
that's glenn beck
wow wow um
big thank you to the 42 people
who just subscribed via twitch prime
that is
unbelievable putting us at 117
also want to say thanks to some new
website subscribers rob
bessie just grabbed a membership stuart
friedman
is a new member ravis lancetovs
has just signed up michael dills is a
new member
katie silverthorne and linda peterson
have just signed up
stand up and fight back as well as
timothy ward have just signed up
brian mullman and michael zawacki have
signed up
also montana mcdonald and willow cats
this is explosive and
miriam rivera all new members putting us
at a hundred and thirty
that is insane oh my god and they're
just dropping in
nicola webber has just signed up
matthew caffrey is a new member
uh as diamond and silk make some kind of
a presentation here
david given that socialism is now in
america what can i do to fight back
against the cancel culture
that's the question cpac is looking to
answer
and maybe donald trump will be able to
answer that
trump is late wonder if he's busy
golfing when trump is in his 90s in a
wheelchair with a frozen jack nicholson
expression on his face
from the end of the shining will
republicans still wheel him
out at their rallies as a crowd pleaser
who knows
who knows i have amazon
prime but i don't use twitch and have no
clue
how to give you my membership there
okay i am going to paste a link
it is a really special link
and it is a guide for how to do exactly
that you've got to link
the two accounts i'm pasting it in
twitch a bunch of times
that should be informative to people
david i didn't know about the freak
prime twitch subscription until i heard
you mention it on your show that's what
i'm
saying it may be that 90 percent of
people don't realize
what is going on with that all right
let's listen in trump
saving our country i never would have
come going for president trump you know
what i like about this number one i'm in
love and you're in love we're all in oh
my god
we've done something that nobody's ever
done
well president trump loves cpac and cpac
loves president trump
it's a mutual strong relationship it's
the fact that the president knows
that when he comes to cpac he's at home
he's with his people you know i first
went to cpac during the reagan years
where reagan was a conservative
president but cpac was much to the right
of even where president reagan was and
now it is right in the senate it is the
republican party
how's cpac doing good huh please we
he's the one who said you should run
right oh my god matt said
it's like five years ago six years ago
and i made a speech
and then they do some kind of a straw
poll who made the best speech
they voted by far the best speech was
trump he calls me he says you should run
for politics
i say what do i know about politics run
for politics quickly
and our country has never done better
than it's doing right now so it's pretty
good
but thank you matt
you know a couple of years ago when a
whole new team of people
all right so i i guess we're sort of
like getting ready for trump's speech
it's not
super clear um it seems like it's
more or less set up at this point in
time
uh but that's uh that's happening
all right thanks to jonah landry big sam
joby juan
dj physique and a whole bunch of other
people
for signing up via twitch prime we just
had a massive dump of
36 twitch prime subs putting us at 168.
unbelievable what's happening there oh
standing by for donald trump
want to say thank you to art evans for
signing up on my website
justin young eric escodall
as well as sarah graceffsky big thank
you to esther lathrum as well as joshua
kelly
and lastly torben de vries
also signing up what am i reading right
now
non-fiction i'm reading john steinbeck's
travels with charlie although from what
i've read it's more fictionalized than
you might imagine i'm also reading
billion dollar loser
about the rise and fall of the company
wework
and adam newman very interesting book
um yes billion dollar loser
from the standpoint of fiction i'm
reading the last policeman
by ben winters i had ben winters on the
program to talk about his more recent
novel
underground airlines really good i am
loving
loving uh the last policeman it's a
trilogy from what i understand
and i'm just reading the first one and
it's great it's
it's really great i highly highly
recommend it to you
will republicans inability to hold trump
accountable and he becomes president
again i worry that trump will try to
remain in power
losing hope for us well we removed him
from power
we removed him from power i heard trans
orca had to look it up trans mountain
expansion oil pipeline
endangers a species of orca in canada
love the show
i will look into that what do i think of
trump supporters of color
his movement is not an all-too-welcoming
base for equality for
all yeah i mean i've there's a lot of
people supporting trump
despite their best interests
uh and it's not unique to folks of color
the singer was the perfect maga
representative proud confident and
utterly clueless incompetent are they
kissing his ass to prevent a third party
listen i mean i'll show this again for
people who missed it this was the
national anthem yesterday
it's it's pretty weaponized
by the dawn's early
light what so
proudly we hailed
at the twilight's last gleaming
whose brought stripes and
bright stars
through the perilous fight
all the ramparts we
watched were so gallantly streaming
[Music]
[Music]
while still there
[Music]
right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so that was that was pretty wild and
again you know we don't want to make fun
of anybody it's great that people are
trying to do things
but if democrats had had that as the
national anthem the republicans would
have said it's disrespectful to the flag
and it reminded me of this it was like
an avant-garde national anthem you guys
remember when yoko ono did this
[Music]
wow
um anyway so that was that was uh
whatever all right david i'm begging you
never to play that version of the
national anthem again and scrub it from
the clip later
david would you debate nick fuentes on
your show it would be funny
i don't know brave rendition of our
national anthem who needs to stay in one
key please stop playing the awful music
fergie did better oh wow that's really
uh
she was not singing the anthem in tune
was she yes
oh i'm told to check toontoon let's see
how things are going up to 56
guys 6k is on the table this
youtube channel has upper management
written all over it
and when when the toontoon cooking
channel
had only 200 subscribers
on friday i mentioned it and we got the
toontoon channel
to about 3 500 subscribers
i mentioned it again today and we're
already
at 56.80 we are bringing
the stock i like the stock i don't know
how else to say it and it is just such a
great
channel making everything from scratch
look at that
mortar and pestle the chilis and the
shallots and the garlic
it is extraordinary look at that paste
that is just something else and in fact
i think i just got a message
toontoon says his phone is blowing up
thank you guys so much love it
beautiful message beautiful beautiful
message uh so on a day where we're
seeing something so weaponized and so
terrible in donald trump speaking
it's great to be look at that go
it's great to be doing something
positive
absolutely love it we are reportedly
moments from trump let's listen
extremely quiet in the space
see what different channels are
broadcasting some are doing propaganda
videos
further live coverage is expected
and then here we are standing by for
donald trump
obviously for the better part of the
next several hours here we just wanted
to give an update on timing some of our
fox reporters
are confirming with their sources on
what exactly is happening because there
is some delay
uh former president trump was supposed
to speak around
oh 25 minutes ago but we're getting some
news
that uh now they're predicting uh trump
will maybe start to speak around
4 55 eastern oh my god 55
mountain time here uh in phoenix arizona
so
in a bit maybe about an hour's time uh
delayed with the former president and
his
speech so um we're gonna be monitoring
that information to see
uh if that is actually uh if it actually
holds up
um and so we'll be get back to you with
any more updates as well
uh we are told also the speech could
last well up to two hours
he hasn't been in front of a microphone
or in front of two hours
it's like fidel castro a lot to say to
get off his plate get off his mind
two hours let's go back to the stage
there maybe we'll get an update again
uh from the acu chief in exactly can you
imagine
to kind of give us an update on what is
happening uh with the former president's
remarks
uh but anyway we um are predicting right
now uh
that's almost satire which uh will
probably now happen
around 4 55 eastern in about 50 minutes
time so
thanks for being with us here on news
now let's go back to this scene right
here from cpac
wow two hour long speech i that that is
that is using a speech as a weapon if
i've ever if i've ever seen one before
uh that that is unbelievable all right
well if that's the case i am gonna
refresh my water and step away just
momentarily and then we'll be back and
and pick it back up
we're gonna keep it right here for the
time being um
and uh see what exactly is going to be
happening we'll keep it here i'll step
away for a moment refresh my water and
then we'll be back donald trump expected
to speak uh soon we're gonna keep going
we're gonna keep going
but uh can you imagine a two-hour speech
by trump
stand by stand back and stand by
what you have is literally thousands of
mostly what i would call
students or kids teenagers some as young
as 12 years old i've been arrested
something i hear all over the globe when
i travel people in maga hats
people saying please tell your president
that for the first time we
have an american leader who's got our
back who's on our side
they're willing to give their lives from
the struggle you know it's a very
emotional thing to see young people
committed to democracy it's completely
the opposite of what they hear when they
turn on cnn international in their
country
about how much the globe is so
embarrassed
of donald trump the movement is now
receiving support from members of the
conservative political action conference
here in
the u.s conservative group joined
student protesters some as young as 12.
i had a young man come on i looked very
american
on the streets of hong kong and he said
are you a sleep man
and i said yeah i i i want to see pep he
goes thank you
you know we make sure we want to tear up
these are really
important times our last night in hong
kong
uh this great patriot who stands for
creator jimmy
invited us to his house and when we
showed up at jimmy's house
there were members of the media who were
essentially communist survives from
media outlets owned by
the regime in beijing they were there to
harass us to make us feel unsafe filming
us as we were walking in
videotaping recording who we are why we
were there we had this conversation
around the table what's at stake what
are the chances that this comes out well
from the people of hong kong
what are the chances that a tiananmen
square type episode occurs
will there be this violent bloody
crackdown
and as we said our goodbyes we head back
to our hotel
we all went to sleep and not many hours
later
we were woken
early up morning by a fire bombing two
masked men lit
glass bottles on fire in front of lies
residents and lobbed them at the gate
the fire bombs were seen as an act of
intimidation against the pro-democracy
tycoon
they were sending us a very clear
message don't we with jimmy
they were sending jimmy a very clear
message don't make me
to see that guys and i think they were
also sending us a message that it was
time for us to leave
we are in minneapolis minnesota a really
important state for a lot of reasons
it is great to have the acu here in
minnesota
home to the only congressional
delegation that makes nancy pelosi look
moderate
today september 11th the 18th
anniversary
of september 11th 2001. just in the
backyard
where we stand today is a congresswoman
who does
not like america who stands for
islamic radicalization she's the one
who said some people did something hair
was founded
9 11 because they recognize
that something so we went up there on 9
11 we held an event called
some people did something they've
convoluted the whole idea of september
11th again and another
shading
all right everybody this is andrew craft
here once again um
we did have a scheduling change that we
just reported
about a couple minutes ago but it looks
like the
former president will not be speaking
until about
4 55 eastern time he was slated to speak
around
3 40 eastern time and so
he's running very very behind and we're
going to be keeping this shot up here as
well
just to see if he does arrive early or
does take the stage or some
intro speakers speak before him there's
been a lot of speakers today
but we are told the speech will last uh
upwards of two hours which is customary
for the former president
and like i said he probably has a lot to
say this is his first time
that he's been in front of a camera and
microphone uh since january the 20th
about a month's time
uh remains to be seen on if
the organizers of cpac will bring anyone
out
to address the crowd beforehand they're
showing some promotional videos
uh for cpac kind of around the world
something i didn't know that
there are cpacs as well
in other places around the world hong
kong the uk
and the like cpac standing for the
conservative political action
conference
we're also going to be speaking to a
reporter after the speech she's live on
the ground for us that's fox 35's alina
shirazi
should be breaking down the speech with
me we're also going to speak to the
spokesperson for young america
uh excuse me the young america
foundation
um spencer brown the spokesman and we're
going to be breaking down the speech as
well a little late excuse me a little
later
after the speech wraps up and so uh you
have that to look forward to but
at the moment we're going to just take a
quick commercial break i know we're just
looking at this podium here of the cpac
stage there in orlando
but sometimes these things happen you
know news now from fox
is live raw and unfiltered uh and so
that's kind of the name of the game here
with
us and our stream we want to thank
everyone for watching but uh just don't
forget
uh we're just the facts with no bias or
opinion
but with context clarity and analysis
we'll be doing that
breaking down the former president's
speech as well after
the fact so i'm andrew kraft you can
follow me on twitter
at andrewcraft you can also follow
newsnow on twitter at newsnowfox we'd
really appreciate that
we just became verified uh and you can
visit our website as well
newsnowfox.com that's where you can tell
your family and friends
where they can go if they want to find
out where they can find us and where
they can watch us it lists
all of our streaming platforms so we're
going to take a quick commercial break
we'll see you back here in two minutes
individualist it's this john wayne kind
of
[Music]
attitude
we joined with acu to create the first
ever
cpac west right here in reno nevada
swing county
and the swing state not only is it
important to trump's reelect
it's important that western libertarian
values of individualism
retain a strong foundation in our
country
bernie sanders was in denver the other
day and said the same thing as barack
obama
the greatest country of god's
[Music]
[Music]
completely supportive of the
constitution and field rights
i had one wonderful woman come up to me
here at cpac west and
literally said i'm inspired i want to
take action
i want to do more and that's what we
need for too long the democrats have
been the ones to organize effectively
it's our turn now it's our turn for
conservatives to take that banner to
win in 2020
korea cpac kicks off in seoul south
korea
and it's hosted by the american
conservative union
just make the statement seek south korea
and think about it
south korea boasts the fourth largest
economy in asia
hence the nickname the korean miracle
but south korean president
moon jae-in is on track to changing that
moon often accused of imposing marxism
on korea
shows alarming sympathica for the
communist policies of north korea
the threat of communism on the peninsula
is growing
and this whole socialism threat that we
have here
in our country is really a problem in so
many corners of the globe
cpac south korea i had to keep pitching
myself
are we really going to go right in the
middle of all that and have a seat
and would anybody show up maria
concluded to a packed ballroom in
seoul's
grand hyatt hotel though 500 were
expected
[Music]
trials and tribulations that they have
that are not so different in some sense
from some of the things that we're
seeing in the united states
america's been facing for the last
couple of years is what korea is now
facing
for itself it's a generational change it
is an inflection point uh what kind of a
life do you want to live
you don't make your stand now it may
never come again
people in georgia are just sick
all right everybody welcome back to news
now from fox i'm andrew kraft uh we'll
be just uh monitoring
that feed we were just showing you there
uh of the cpac stage in orlando florida
with the podium
all set to go the stage all set to go
we're just waiting uh
for the main player of the moment uh
former president donald trump who is
running late he's running about an hour
late we're told that
the speech will kind of start right now
around 4 55
pm eastern 2 55 pm mountain time here in
phoenix arizona so
i want to thank everyone for watching we
know it's a little bit of a longer wait
than you had anticipated but don't go
anywhere because
the speech we're told is expected to be
about uh two
hours in length uh as you know this is
his first speech
since he left the white house in front
of uh tv and cameras and
uh a microphone so um it's going to be
uh probably a pretty long one so we're
going to go back to that shot i'm going
to read some of uh
excerpts that fox has obtained from the
speech itself
this is new you're not you're going to
want to listen to this uh and then
i'll just be coming in and out of the
feed itself kind of updating you on
what we're seeing when we're expecting
the former president and some of the
context as well
given everything that's gone on since he
left office and joe biden took over
as the 46th president
so as i've said uh previously uh
throughout the day trump is not expected
to announce a 2024 run
in in his speech he instead he'll focus
on the immediate future of the
republican party as you remember
uh 2020 the republicans lost control of
the senate
2018 republicans lost control of the
house and 2020 they lost control of the
white house as well
so he's expected to kind of
approach that idea that will set up
a new party committing instead to the
gop and laying out a path
to it taking back congress in 2022
remember i was
explaining to you as well to our viewers
that a lot of that third party talk that
was
kind of circulating out there that they
thought former president trump was going
to start
a new political party it's been kind of
watered down
tamp down he's not going to do that but
in an excerpt
of the speech obtained by fox news trump
is expected to say
quote we are not starting new parties
and we will not be dividing our power
and our strength
instead we will be united and strong
like never before
so uh unity obviously
a main message of the biden white house
going to be a main message here on the
cpac stage although
trump will take issue and probably no
holds barred
comments on some of his republican
detractors in his own party i'm thinking
congressman adam kinzinger congresswoman
liz
cheney possibly mitch mcconnell
possibly kevin mccarthy some of these
more establishmentarian type republicans
some of whom even voted to impeach him
and voted to convict
him in his trial
so look out be on the lookout for that i
know i'll be looking out for that
and just to kind of give a recap of cpac
in general we've been showing you
speeches from a lot of
main players in the republican party
including
senator rick scott of florida senator
tom cotton senator ted cruz senator josh
hawley
florida governor ron desantis we saw a
former
secretary of state of state for
president trump mike pompeo
also the south dakota governor christie
noem
one thing that really struck out to me
was that former vice president mike
pence
was not there
at cpac this year at the moment so
there were some reports that president
trump former president trump asked him
not to be there
i don't know if fox had confirmed any of
those
uh anyway let's go over to it looks like
acu head match slap is taking questions
from reporters in the lobby of the
convention center
it leads to my next question which is
entitled this lie
that joe biden stole the election for
weeks
he did it again in a speech on january
6th are you concerned about having a
president
back here at cpac where he's going to
continue to say
that the election was stolen but that
just wasn't true were there any illegal
ballots cast in that election
i suppose there might have been so but
bill barnes
his own attorney general so not enough
to overturn the results of the election
believe it or not had no court decision
after court decision
he put three justices
he just told me that that's actually not
right he just told me that there was
illegal voting
in the last election you don't know how
many
did you sit down with the team in the
back let me finish
did you sit down with a team in nevada
or georgia in these states
and never go through the binders of
information
that good patriotic americans came up
with but did you ever talk to overturn
how could you
[Music]
magazine and to read the new york times
read the washington post
they're saying there's less than a
hundred thousand votes that separated
the two man
electorally and you just said that
conservatives
spur violence but you can't use any
words
you admit that there's obviously all
conservatives right there were
troublesome
you have no idea how much but you are
certain
isn't this the big lie conference that's
what the nazis used to say
you're better than that you're better
than that you're you're comparing you're
comparing me to another
is the big lie come on
i love you man i'm glad you're
thank responsible responsible
[Music]
and this is andrew craft here once again
i was under the impression that that was
live happening outside the convention
center ballroom
um but it looked like that happened
about a couple of days ago that was
acu's
american conservative unions matt
schlapp who puts on cpac
kind of going toe-to-toe there with
cnn's jim acosta
most of our viewers probably recognized
him
so it does seem there is some activity
happening right now
at the beginning of the stage let's
let's listen in
she told me
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
cheers
is
is
so
you know one of the things i love
about the twitch following is that when
i step away momentarily
nobody leaves everybody just sticks
around it's fantastic
um youtube people just they'll just
leave
they just leave but twitch sticks around
i really like that
okay we are somewhere between five and
25 minutes from donald trump's speech he
reportedly has already landed and is on
his way
over and um
scheduled now i guess for 4 55 although
it could be sooner or not and it may go
two hours or maybe it won't
uh this is gonna be i predict completely
and utterly insane
uh we are standing by for donald trump's
first speech since leaving the white
house
and it is going to be absolutely insane
uh glad people are here i have my water
refreshed
oh my god had a little snack and we are
very very much ready to go
let me get caught up as far as
could this be right hold on a second
1646
19 81
new twitch subscribers just signed up is
that possible 81
um huh
that's interesting 81.
crazy okay that puts us at 266 i guess
that's real
um okay trump is the opposite of a
smooth criminal says alice in your
absence the commentator reported trump
is
not expected to announce a 2024 run yeah
i heard that i was monitoring as well
i can't believe you're doing this i'm
here for it oh let's see if they have an
update
in about an hour behind schedule we're
told he's going to be speaking around
2 55 p.m mountain time 4 55 p.m there
on the east coast in orlando florida at
cpac
and i believe this will be i think this
is the last day of the conference itself
ending with the former president's
speech uh on sunday so
uh we'll be kind of monitoring these
feeds uh in the next 20-25 minutes or so
but uh i i've been giving you know
commentary yes excellent excellent
commentary that he's been giving let's
see what else we have here
uh here's one feed and then here is
another feed
the cleanest feed right now seems to be
this one
so maybe we'll just make sure that we're
in hd
oh phil collins give me a break there's
no way phil wants this being played
okay so we're we're going to monitor
that feed and and things are
things are upcoming okay i have a ton of
people to thank for signing up on my
website
i promise thank you so i want to make
sure i hit everybody
thanks to michelle wolf
kenny jane johnson big thank you
to peggy sally
as well as jamie young and an
extra special thank you to jurgen bomb
jurgen bomb us 271
a powerful powerful number today
i have to leave now listening to trump
is bad enough but michael jackson put me
over the edge
gab was hacked the ceo and trump's
accounts were compromised i barely even
know what gab is
i know it's some some right wing uh
website i don't even know
wondering if we could make a democratic
equivalent to cpac and realize democrats
don't have as many voters who make their
politics their whole life do you agree
well net roots nation is sort of like a
thinking left-wing
cpac in a way and i've been to netroots
nation
a bunch of times it's not exactly the
same it's more of a media conference and
it's also
not crazy it's not weaponized in the
same way
but uh yeah i mean i think the the right
is better at organizing in in a
particular type of way
and whether it translates to electoral
victories depends on the kind of
specifics of what
what you're talking about um
okay other oh i missed some messages via
twitch let me get to those kenny just
said thanks
zach subscribed for 11 months and says
trump is back baby
being been missing the messy [ __ ] drama
wow that's a that's aggressive other
super
other twitch prime messages i think i
got most of the recent ones
i'm a dad says great work on the show
david thank you
who else do we have yeah that's as far
back as i can see right now
but i do appreciate dtf machine as well
as trevigeo
great job spaghett and uh
kenny's prague rock jukebox
all for signing up we just had an
additional dump of 14
14 twitch subs drop in
and uh i i actually thought at the start
of this stream
this might be our worst month ever from
the standpoint of twitch subs
and website subs maybe but a bunch of
people have just dropped in out of
nowhere
and uh very yeah i i mentioned earlier
that 90
of twitch viewers don't even know that
they have a twitch prime
sub they can use it almost seems like
that might be right
coming up oh what's coming up this week
on the show great question let me tell
you what's coming up
i don't know myself i'm going to try to
figure it out right now pulling up the
schedule
tuesday i will be interviewing the great
michael moss who wrote the new york
times
best-selling book uh heat sugar
salt fat i'm missing one of them what's
it called sugar salt
heat sugar salt fat something like that
he has a new book salt fat acid heat no
that's not it
anyway michael moss will be all on the
show noah feldman will be on the show on
wednesday you might remember him from
the first impeachment of donald trump
legal scholar and author of a new book
he will be great to talk to and then
james fletcher will be on on thursday
he's the producer director of that great
documentary the accidental president in
which i am featured
next week i will be interviewing
jonathan berman and nicole pearl roth
and then upcoming later in march gnome
chomsky
as well as many others if you don't
remember
about me being in the accidental
president
accidental president
here is the trailer for the accidental
president
and bear in mind that i'm in the trailer
but you've got to look
quickly or you might miss me okay here
it is let's go volume up
it was a perfect storm really that's it
that's my presence in the trailer
that's the that's my that's my full
participation in the trailer
i'm in the film much more but as far as
the trailer goes that's it
it was a perfect storm really
i asked for 12 takes and i also ripped a
production assistant a new one because i
didn't have brown skittles and they were
like sir
brown is m ms not skittles there's no
brown skittle i was like
i said brown skittles you got to get me
the brown skittles so it was
controversial it was in my rider
as people say uh jameson shalpey says
it's toon time david oh yeah let's see
how our let's see how
toontoon's channel is doing up to 6200
beautiful absolutely beautiful
uh okay very very good
been watching for four years of trump
stupidity still here to support you says
jeez viresma i hope i'm pronouncing that
correctly
um other super chats keep up the good
work mate
insane times this cpac is like something
out of the running man
america has lost itself to a pervertedly
charismatic
showman yes indeed yes indeed very very
well said
um people are getting excited because
we're expecting to hear from donald
trump in the next 15 minutes or so
i do want to say thank you to ross
dinwiddle
ross dinwiddle just signed up for a
membership
at joinpackman.com using
the coupon code above my head better21
uh when do i think we will get to 1.3
million we we're at 1.3 million we had
we hit 1.3 million twitch subs yesterday
i was in bed with flu-like symptoms from
my second
vaccine dose but i did uh come out of a
stupor long enough to see
that um we hit 1.3
million youtube subs
uh what else do we have
sabrina wants to know what i'm wearing
a maroon sweater what do you mean
isn't it obvious thanks to lord thunder
for gifting five subs on twitch also
thanks to chop chop and tim shofield jay
harrison rickert sends a super chat and
says use this to br
buy brown skittles i'm not wrong that
there aren't brown skittles right
skittles
brown would be a like what fruit would
be brown
i know m ms can be brown because they're
chocolate
there are brown skittles oh i didn't
know that
grape no that's purple that's purple
it's ridiculous
avocado give me give me a break guys
best meal kit delivery service i'll tell
you when one sponsors my show
actually this is a funny this is you
guys want to here's a funny story
let me give you guys a funny story so as
many of you know i make no secret of the
fact that i don't um
i don't really own individual stocks i
own a few individual stocks but i mostly
own mutual funds because i don't think
that i'm
i have what do i know about picking
individual stocks
one of the worst investments i ever made
was when blue apron was one of our
sponsors let me see if i can find this
we used to have blue apron the meal kit
delivery service as a sponsor
and um where is this
and they ipo'd and at the time that they
were a sponsor i said you know what
if they are smart enough to invest in
our show
i'm going to participate in the ipo i
threw 5 grand
at the stock and because i like the
stock
as many of you know and
it turned out that uh blue blue apron
was i need to be careful of the wording
blue apron was then immediately accused
of dramatically overstating
their customer retention like basically
all this all the data on which the ipo
pricing was based
was allegedly fraudulent and
it's basically worth nothing at this
point my five grand is worth like 200
bucks
or something like that so this is my
worst investment that i've ever made
now as some of you know i did make some
other investments
at about mid-march uh around march 20th
when the pandemic
struck one of them is live nation my
thought was
live nation uh is crashing
but i believe it will eventually do well
so i got in that one right around
april 1st and it went bonkers and live
nation now is figuring out ways to do
you know vaccine passports to do live
events and all this other stuff
so that one did really well um
what else did i buy at the beginning of
the pandemic zoom video i did
and um obviously that's done really
really well that tripled which is wild
what else uh i did roku
and the reason i did roku was i've been
invested in netflix for about
six years now so it's like i wasn't
gonna just buy more netflix
so i did around when was it it was all
around the same time right around april
1.
i got into roku here thinking with
people at home demand for these types of
services will go up
i'm already in netflix so i'm not going
to do more this one went crazy this
looks like about
5x on roku
and then what else you know uh i did
bayer i don't know why my thought was
maybe bayer will do something
uh related to medications that we need
so i got in that one right around this
same period it's basically even
nothing happened with that one um
and then of course uh famously i am
still
in tesla i've been in tesla since 2015.
where was it i think it was february
2015 i got in tesla around here
and uh i've just been holding i know
everybody says sell sell sell it's
overvalued it's overvalued but
i'm still into but but again i don't
believe
that i have any special ability to pick
individual stocks
so i i keep almost everything in mutual
funds
low cost five to ten basis points
no loads no you know extra management
fees or anything like that
all right i'm holding the line i like
the stock
david your former president is very
often laid especially
with his stage around 90 years
greetings from germany okay
david as long as you're promoting
youtube channels could you give a shout
out to my no
i'm i listen we have an ad program and
sometimes we promote youtube channels
that way i
will only promote channels that i
personally you know
want to recommend or that i watch or
whatever that's why i talked about oh by
the way by the way
i mentioned this the other day and a lot
of people thought that i was kidding
about it
let me pull this up this was not a joke
whatsoever
uh the celebrity chef tyler florence
is a fan of the david pakman show i
wasn't joking when i said that
and he has an awesome channel which is a
combination of the sort of cooking type
videos we've come to know tyler
florence for as well as
a sort of long-form podcast type format
he's a big booster of the david pakman
show i wasn't kidding when i said
this is a great channel to subscribe to
i watch this all the time
and some of the recipe videos this one
right here
the new rule on roasted chicken
this has blown wide open the debate on
the right way to roast the chicken
i don't want to even take sides on this
issue i really don't
um but i i would this has been he has
basically
weaponized spatchcocking of chickens
that's all
that i want to say but in all
seriousness the wolf it down channel
with tyler florence
excellent excellent channel i'll paste a
few links to it
in the uh in twitch here this
people say what do you watch on youtube
i never watch any politics
this is the type of stuff i watch quite
frankly so anyway
um i know a few hundred people followed
up and subscribed to tyler's
channel good guy big supporter
of independent progressive media and
highly highly recommend his channel
other super chats coming in trump is
late because he's putting the finishing
touches on his health care plan
we're really getting close to learning
about trump's health care plan
any day now i bought 100 shares of
spirit airlines for nine dollars it's
now 35 dollars a share nicely done
dogecoin david dogecoin to the moon
that i know nothing about see what's
going on here
[Music]
i'm so glad i'm not there when i see
stuff like this i'm so glad i'm just
sitting in the studio
big thank you to christopher tomlin for
signing up at joinpacman.com
also thanks to brad willett for signing
up
at joinpackman.com
oh my god it's trump he's here look at
this
donald trump's first speech since
leaving office
[Music]
i'm cringing welcome 3k on twitch
appreciate it
to be living here today
cause the flag still stands for freedom
this is sad
it is sad in a way
[Music]
the stream is glitching we're gonna
switch to another one
this one's way behind though that's
annoying let's just refresh this one and
see if it'll be
smoother
[Music]
yikes
[Music]
is he just gonna stand there for the
entire song just clapping like a buffoon
is he gonna show up and say god bless
the united sheish
[Music]
he's actually not looking great i'm not
that that's that from the picture we
looked at
he he really isn't looking great i
thought that that was a joke but
um yeah i don't know i don't know what
how to describe it exactly but this
should be interesting um
expect it to be potentially a two-hour
speech uh reminiscent of uh fidel
castro's endless endless endless
speeches
and we will see uh whether the crowd
likes it or doesn't like it i would
expect with a two-hour speech
um we may have that dead absolutely dead
silent crowd
trump doesn't even look that thrilled to
be here i'm not going to lie
this is really really strange
wowza
[Music]
i think antifa's running sound
engineering for this conference
if the stream does glitch i've got three
backup feeds we can switch to
just bear with me as we figure it out
[Applause]
well thank you very much and hello cpac
do you miss me yet
do you miss me not really
a lot of things going on
to so many wonderful friends
conservatives and fellow citizens in
this room and all across our country i
stand before you today
to declare that the incredible journey
we've begun
together we went through a journey like
nobody else there's
never been a journey like it there's
never been a journey so successful
right we began it together four years
ago and it is
far from being over
[Applause]
it's already great
our movement of proud hard work and you
know what this is the hardest work
hard hard-working america that was a
glitch already
is just getting started and in the end
we will win we will win weird glitch
we've been doing a lot of winning as we
gather this week we're in the middle of
a historic struggle for america's future
america's culture and america's
institutions
borders and most cherished principles
our security our prosperity and our very
identity as americans is at stake
like perhaps at no other time
so no matter how much the washington
establishment and the powerful
special interests may want to silence us
let there be no doubt we will be
victorious and america will be stronger
and greater than ever
before
thanks to you being god i think
i want to thank my great friends matt
and mercedes schlapp
matt thank you thank you mercedes thank
you very much
and the american conservative union for
hosting this extraordinary event they're
talking about it all over the world man
yeah for how stupid it is all over the
world i
also want to pay my love and respect to
the great
rush limbaugh can you imagine
who is watching closely
and smiling down on us he's watching and
he's loving it and he
loves catherine catherine thank you for
being here so great thank you kathryn
he loved you catherine i will tell you
that
this is cringy i don't even want to
comment to each and every one of you
here at cpac
i am more grateful to you than you will
ever
know we are gathered this afternoon to
talk about the future of our movement
the future of our party and the future
of our beloved country
for the next four years the brave
republicans in this room will be at the
heart of the effort to oppose the
radical democrats the fake news media
and their toxic cancer culture something
new to our ears
cancer culture trump's adding that to
his routine i want you to know that i'm
going to continue to fight
right by your side we will do
what we've done right from the beginning
which is to win
we're not starting new parties
you know they kept saying he's going to
start a brand new party
we have the republican party someone
talked him out of that
and be stronger than ever before i am
not sure we will
march to the capitol wait wait wait
figuratively
fake news no wouldn't that be brilliant
let's start a new party and let's divide
our vote
so that you can never win no we're not
interested in that now we have
he's right they would never win again mr
mclaughlin just gave me numbers that
nobody's ever heard of before
more popular than anybody that's all of
us it's all of us
those are great numbers mr mclaughlin i
came here and he was giving me 95
97 92 92
what i said they're great and i want to
thank everybody in this room and
everybody all throughout the country
throughout the world if you want to
really know the truth
thank you though thank you
we will be united this is wild like
never before
we will save and strengthen america and
we will
fight the onslaught of radicalism
socialism
and indeed it all leads to communism
once and for all that's what it leads to
you'll be hearing more and more about
that as we go along
any day we'll be communist we all knew
that the biden administration was
going to be bad but none of us even
imagined
just how bad they would be and how far
left they would go he never talked about
this who believes that we would have
those wonderful debates he would never
talk about this
we didn't know what the hell he was
talking about actually the debate trump
showed up out with covid
his campaign was all lies talked about
energy i thought i said you know this
guy actually he's okay with energy he
wasn't okay with energy
he wants to put you all out of business
he's not okay with energy he wants
windmills
the windmills the windmills that
don't work when you need them whoever
predicted windmills you were right
he's had the most disastrous first month
of any president
in modern history
covet cases down 70 percent vaccines
more than doubled
that they are anti-jobs anti-family
anti-borders anti-energy
anti-women and anti-science
they're against women they want only men
in just one short month we have gone
from
america first to america last
you think about it right america last
there is no better example than the new
and horrible crisis on our southern
border
that has to be a joke it all worked
nobody's ever seen anything like we did
now that must be a joke
when i left office just six weeks ago we
had created the most secure border in
u.s history
we had built almost 500 miles of
great border wall that helped us with
these numbers because
once it's up you know they used to say a
wall doesn't work well
you know what i've always said walls and
wheels those are two things that will
never change
the wall has been amazing it's been
incredible and little sections of it to
complete they don't want to complete it
they don't want to complete little
sections in certain little areas they
don't want to complete but
it's had an impact that nobody would
have even believed
it's amazing considering that the
democrats number one priority was to
make sure that the wall would never
ever get built would never ever happen
and it didn't never get financed we got
it financed we ended catch and release
ended asylum fraud and brought illegal
crossings to
historic lows when illegal aliens
trespass
across our borders they were promptly
caught detained
and sent back home and these were some
rough customers i want to tell you some
rough customers were
entering our country it took the new
administration only a few weeks to turn
this
unprecedented accomplishment into a
self-inflicted humanitarian
and national security disaster that has
to be a joke by recklessly eliminating
our border
security measures controls all of the
things that we put into place
joe biden has triggered a massive flood
of illegal immigration
into our country the likes of which we
have never seen before they're coming up
by never tens of thousands
so quickly it has to take advantage of
the things that he said that's luring
everybody to come to
america and we're one country
we can't afford the problems of the
world
as much as we'd love to we'd love to
help but we can't do that
so they're all coming because of
promises and foolish words
this is the speech trump lost on
decision to cancel border security
has single-handedly launched a youth
migrant crisis
that is enriching child smugglers
vicious criminal cartels
and some of the most evil people on the
planet
you see it every day just turn on the
news you'll see it every day
under my administration we stop the
child smugglers
we dismantle the criminal cartels we
greatly limited drug and human
trafficking to a level that
nobody actually thought was possible and
the wall helped us a lot
the audience is already getting bored
yeah people
slowly they're starting to get bored the
ravages of dangerous predators and
that's what they are dangerous dangerous
predators but the biden administration
has put the vile
coyotes back in business and it has done
so in a very very big way
under the new administration catch and
release
has been restored can you imagine you
work
so hard catch you know where that is you
catch them
you take their name they may be killers
they may be rapists they may be
drug smugglers they may be as bad as
trump released them into our country
we did the opposite we not only didn't
release them we had them brought back to
their country
illegal immigrants are now being
apprehended
and released along the entire southern
border just the opposite of what it was
two months ago they weren't coming
because they couldn't get in
once they think they can get in they're
coming and they are coming at levels
that you haven't even seen yet
by the hundreds of thousands by the
millions they'll be coming
the biden administration is now actively
expediting the admission of illegal
migrants
enabling them to lodge frivolous asylum
claims and admitting them
by the thousands and thousands and
thousands a day
crowded together in unsanitary
conditions despite the ongoing economic
and public health crisis covet 19
or as i call it the china virus
yeah the crowd loves china virus
imagine cheering for that no masks
there's no double mass that was a new
one that came out two weeks ago
first vouch he said you don't eat mask
no mess
no good no no then all of a sudden you
want him now he wants double masks
no social distancing no nothing
no nothing they're together
and it's sad actually and it said for
them and it said for our country
this is what the biden administration is
doing to push
young migrants into the hands of human
traffickers and coyotes
is dangerous immoral and indefensible
hard to believe it's happening biden has
failed in his number one duty as chief
executive
enforcing america's laws
what's he talking about this alone
should be reason enough
for democrats to suffer withering losses
in the midterms
and to lose the white house
decisively four years from now
that guy really wants trump running in
2024.
the guy with the uh the big suit there
loves the idea of 2024
this is sad it really is it's just so
sad for the country
actually as you know they just lost the
white house but that's what
there it is there it is but who knows
who knows i may even decide to beat them
for a third time
okay there you go
it's a very sick man but the real sick
people are the ones who clap
those are the really sick people
there's no deprogramming of these folks
happening anytime soon
joe biden defunded the border wall and
stopped all
future construction even on small open
sections that just needed to be finished
up
routine little work it's already been
bought
way to the contractors get to them and
they say no it costs us much
more money not to finish the small
section than if we finished it that's
going to be nice where do you see those
bills start pouring in he revoked the
executive order cracking down on deadly
sanctuary cities
he has effectively ordered a shutdown of
ice
halting virtually all deportations
everyone
murders everybody they're not shut down
a judge didn't allow it to be shut down
and restricting our law enforcement
professionals and they are great
professionals you have many of them
represented here today
from conducting almost any immigration
enforcement of any kind
the biden policy of releasing criminals
into the u.s interiors making america
into a sanctuary nation where criminals
illegal immigrants including gang
members and sex offenders are set free
into american communities
they have no idea who's coming up and
remember with the caravans
right these countries not only the three
of them
but many many countries all over the
world they're not giving us their best
and their finest
there it is because they're intelligent
they're not giving us their best
and their finest rehashing i said that
a long time ago when i made the first
remarks when i came down the escalator
with our great future first lady
and she said sir mention the rapist
who loves you as much as i love you
but i said that a long time ago and we
turned out to be
100 percent correct biden's radical
immigration policies aren't just illegal
they're immoral they're heartless and
they are a betrayal of our nation's core
values it's a terrible thing that's
happening
the republican party must hold joe biden
and the democrats
accountable they ripped up the
diplomatic agreements we negotiated with
honduras guatemala
and el salvador to shut down illegal
immigration
you know they got a fortune they got
paid 500 million dollars a year
when i came into office those countries
were
refusing to take back illegal alien gang
members including ms-13
the most vicious probably of them all no
matter where you go in the world ms-13
they do things that
even the worst don't think about so i
asked how much do we pay these countries
how much do we pay them they told me sir
we pay them approximately 500 million
dollars a year
i mean it's peanuts compared to the way
other countries rip us off but that's a
lot of money
i said okay we aren't going to pay them
anymore
because they wouldn't take back the
criminals and this was true with the
obama administration it was true for
many many years
so we'd catch a murderer we'd want to
bring them back to guatemala or
honduras el salvador
they wouldn't take them back no we don't
want them we'd fly them in they wouldn't
let the plane land would bust them in
they wouldn't let the buses get anywhere
near the border
and i said if you think this is
rehashing ancient history wait till he
does his hillary material
payment you know like a term that we use
in
the world of business let's stop payment
so we stopped payment they would
delinquent
we stopped payment and they very quickly
came to the table and we made a deal
very quick deal
we still kept the money we still didn't
pay because
of course we made a deal that's trump's
move
and when illegal aliens came across our
border
they were rapidly deported and lovingly
accepted by those countries
from where they came and it worked out
great so now they accept the people
and then we ultimately got along very
well with those countries those three
countries and many countries throughout
the world because they respected us
again
they didn't respect us they couldn't
believe what they were getting away with
but now joe biden has wrecked this great
deal
wrecked it and they're already doing
what they were doing before and they're
taking the money
and that's just a small portion of
what's going on to top it all off
the biden people are pushing a bill that
would grant mass amnesty for millions of
illegal aliens
while massively expanding chain
migration that's where you come in and
everybody
comes in your grandmother sort of like
melania mother your mother
and her parents yeah cousins they come
in
so easily so so crazy so crazy
it even requires that the us government
provide illegal border crosses
with taxable funded lawyers lawyers
anybody need a good lawyer you can't
have one
they get the lawyers they get lawyers
they're probably very good too
the democrat immigration bill is a
globalist corporate
you take a look at the corporatists big
tech attack on hard-working citizens of
every race
they say it's a globalist corp or
cope that it never is allowed
to become federal law which is what they
want to do
we must stand tall in the party
we have to do this we have did he
pronounce coup as cope
for law abiding americans and
others when they're in our country
border security is just one of the many
issues on which the new administration
has already betrayed the american people
he didn't talk about this stuff i
debated him he wasn't talking about this
he wasn't
what he signed with those executive
orders
they weren't things that were discussed
we didn't know all about
him and the press because they're fake
news they're the biggest fakers there
are
but the prisoners know about the press
refuse to ask the questions and when i
ask the questions on television on the
debate
chris wallace in this case and others
refused to let him answer
they refused to let him answer what is
he talking about questions maybe we
could have found something or if the
media did its job which they don't
their callous indifference to working
families equally clear when it comes to
the critical matter of getting america's
children back to school
and they must get back and get back
right
now the crowd looks really bored other
than when there's key applause lines and
then people take it as an opportunity to
go nuts
desperate for entertainment
terrible the biden administration is
actually bragging about the classroom
education they are providing
to migrant children on the border while
at the same time millions of american
children
are having their futures destroyed by
joe biden's
anti-science school closures think of it
we're educating students on the border
but our own people the children of
our citizens citizens themselves
are not getting the education that they
deserve there's no reason whatsoever why
the vast majority of young americans
should not be back in school
immediately
the only reason that most parents do not
have that choice
is because joe biden sold out america's
children
to the teachers union it's essentially
no policies on school closures have
changed since trump left other than more
schools opening and it's up to governors
not biden early
inexcusable you know that joe biden has
shamefully betrayed america's youth
and he is cruelly keeping our children
locked in their homes
no reason for it whatsoever they want to
get out
they're cheating the next generation of
americans out of
the future that they deserve and they do
deserve this future they're going to
grow up
and they're going to have a scar it's a
scandal of the highest order and one of
the most
craven acts by any president
in our lifetimes it's the teachers union
it's the votes
and it shouldn't happen and i have
nobody has more respect for teachers
than i do
right and i'll bet you a lot of the
people within that union they
agree with everything i'm saying even
the new york times is calling out the
democrats
the mental and physical health of these
young people
is reaching a breaking point tragically
suicide attempts have skyrocketed and
student depression is now
commonplace and at levels that we've
never seen before
the democrats now say we have to pass
their 1.9 trillion dollar boondoggle to
open schools but a very small part of it
has to do with that you know where it's
going it's going to bail out
badly run democrat cities so much of it
but billions of dollars for schools
remain unspent
from the covert relief bills that were
passed last year
so on behalf of the moms dads and
children of america i call on joe biden
to get the schools
open and get them open now that's
biden's plan
it's weird because biden's big plan was
i want schools at least partially in
person by the end of my first hundred
days
when i left office and were very proud
of this because this was something that
they said could not be done
the fda said it everybody said it any
article you read said it couldn't be
done it would be years and years i
handed the new administration what
everyone is now calling
a modern day medical miracle some say
it's the greatest thing to happen
in hundreds of years hundreds of years
two vaccines produced in record time
with numerous others on the
how does a vaccine develop by two
turkish immigrants to germany depend on
trump
and therapeutic relief also if you're
sick
if you're sick we have things now that
are incredible
what has taken place over the last year
under our administration it would have
taken
any other president at least five years
and we got it done in nine months
everyone says five years so
five years
can you imagine if you had to go through
what all of the countries of the world
who are now
getting the vaccine or soon will be
getting it from various
companies but can you imagine if all of
those
countries had to go through what they've
been going through over the last year
you'd lose
hundreds of millions of people i pushed
the fda
like they have but we have a higher
death rate than most of those countries
they have never been pushed like i
pushed them i didn't like them at all
but once we got it done i said i now
love you very much
what the trump administration has done
with vaccines as in many respects
perhaps saved large portions of the
world not
only our country but large portions of
the world
this is like scary delusional push the
fda far beyond what the bureaucrats
wanted to do
we also put up billions and billions of
dollars 10 billion
to produce the vaccines before we knew
they were going to work
that's standard it was called a
calculated bet or
a calculator would have been criminal
not to do that because if we didn't do
that
you still wouldn't have the vaccines you
wouldn't have them for a long time so
think of that we took this
this bet we made a bet because we
thought we were on a certain track
but you'd be starting to make them right
now would be
a long time before you ever saw him it
takes 60 to 100 days to manufacture
and inspect new doses and that means
that 100
of the increased availability that we
have now
was initiated by our administration it's
all
trump guys they're cheering for a
vaccine they don't even want
that they think they don't even know the
director of national institutes of
health
francis collins he's fouchy's boss
actually i think he's a democrat too by
the way
recently said that our operation warp
speed was
absolutely breathtaking and that the
trump administration
deserves full credit which we do
wow
and as conservatives and republicans
never forget that we didn't
never let them take the credit because
they don't deserve the credit
they just followed now they're following
our plan but
this has been something that they really
call they call it a
an absolute miracle joe biden is only
implementing the plan that
we put in place and we had
an honest media which we don't they
would say it loud and clear
uh-oh by the time i left that
magnificent house
oh no you don't want to restart avenue
almost 20 million americans had already
been vaccinated
bad time to restart 5 million doses were
administered on my final day alone
1.5 million in a day yet biden said just
a few days ago
that when he got here meaning the white
house there was no vaccine
he said there's no vaccine oh
say it again joe
now i don't think he said that frankly
in a malicious way i really don't
i actually believe he said that because
he didn't really know
what the hell was happening here's the
dementia talk
this guy loves it never let them forget
this was us we did this and the
distribution
is moving along according to our plan
and it's moving along
really well
we had the military what they've done
our general
for how many months will trump take
credit for anything good that happens
remember you know we took care of a lot
of people
including i guess on december 21st we
took care of joe biden
because he got his shot he got his
vaccine he forgot it shows you how
unpainful that vaccine shot is so
everybody go get your [ __ ]
has trump gotten him so it wasn't very
traumatic obviously
but he got a shot and it's good that he
got a shot
last year i predicted to you that the
extremist
corruption and incompetence of the biden
administration
would be literally unprecedented in
american history
unfortunately he has proven me 100
percent
right already
as president biden has urged congress to
pass legislation
shredding your second amendment your
second amendment is in far bigger
trouble than you
know and for four years i fought like
hell to save your second amendment
and we saved it 100 percent right
would have been dead he signed an order
to conduct
politically correct far far-left
indoctrination trainings in every
department of the federal government
including the u.s military after i had
terminated
these horrible things that were being
preached to our military
and he wants it to go forward it's
insane
within his first few hours biden
eliminated our national security travel
bans or nations plagued by terrorism
his first priority was to open our
borders to unvetted travelers from libya
yemen syria somalia and many other
countries where strict vetting
cannot occur countries that have
tremendous problems countries with
tremendous
terrorism problems we did a travel ban
it was a real achievement we told those
countries
sorry straighten out your act we don't
want people coming in
where they had an ideology or a problem
we just couldn't have
it and it was incredible how it worked
was incredible
and he terminated it we had to get it
approved it went all the way up to the
supreme court of the united states we
got it approved and he terminates it in
addition
he's already increased refugee
admissions by nearly 10 times but in
effect it'll soon be hundreds of times
as millions of people flow up
through our soon-to-be open borders
any day they're opening by the way the
border patrol and isis are some of the
great heroes of our country these are
incredible people
i got to know him very well
your family still cannot go out to eat
at local restaurants but joe biden is
bringing in thousands upon
thousands of refugees restaurants are
basically open almost everywhere the
question is capacity
many of them are almost back to normal
don't have crime records
we don't have health records what are
they bringing in with them
when i left office we had virtually
ended the endless wars
these endless wars they go on forever
they go on forever
i would go to dover and i would see
caskets coffins coming in i'd see the
parents and the wives and husbands i
would see the kids
endless wars 19 years in afghanistan we
have it down to almost
nothing left and i hear they might want
to go back in
uh iraq remember i used to say don't go
in but if you're going to go in keep the
oil well we went in and we didn't keep
the oil
we had made historic peace deals in the
middle east
like nobody thought were even possible
between countries not at war
with not a drop of bloodshed well yeah
they weren't fighting
how would there be blood
and by the way not one american soldier
has been killed in afghanistan
in over a year think of that not one
those troops have largely come home at
the same time
the new administration unilaterally
withdrew our
crippling sanctions on iran foolishly
giving away all of america's leverage
before
negotiations have even begun leave the
sanctions negotiated
does anybody understand what i'm saying
here okay
are there any good business people you
don't have to be a good are there any
bad business people
they took off the center that business
people there are yeah they took off the
sanctions they say well we're going to
not
have any sanctions let's negotiate a
deal i don't know matt schlapp i don't
think you would have done that do you
think so man i don't think so mercedes
wouldn't have
now you do that you make a deal and then
you do it they wanted
i will tell you something and i said it
had
we had a fair election the results
would have been much different and we
would have had a deal
we would have had a deal with iran
within the first week they wanted those
sanctions off he took them off for
nothing
for nothing now you watch how tough they
negotiate
in another horrendous surrender he
agreed to
get back into the world health
organization
boo terrible for approximately 500
million dollars a year which is what we
were paying
when i withdrew from the w.h.o
and you know the whole story with that
they called it badly
they really are puppets for china
they called and they wanted us to stay
in oh man i said
how much are we paying approximately 500
million dollars how much is
china paying a much larger the trumpian
thing to do would be to stay in but
don't pay
sir they're paying 39 million dollars i
said why are we paying 500 million and
they're paying 39
i could tell you why because the people
that made the deal is stupid that's why
so so
and i had no idea how popular it was i
didn't even know if i would be able to
politically because people were so happy
when i did get out
but i said so we went in we could get it
for 39 million which is what china not
500 million which is what we were
stupidly paying and they said
we can make a deal we want you to go in
we can make a deal
okay and i did i decided not to do it
but we could have had it for 39. we
could have had it for the same as
china and they decide now
to go back into the world health
organization this is wild
hey 500 million what the hell is wrong
with them
no no this is just this is just
emblematic it's a tremendous amount of
money but compared to trillions it's not
but it's a tremendous amount of money
why would china pay 39 million and we're
paying almost 500 million
why so we could have made the same deal
that china had 39 million
and they just say we're going back in
we're going back into the world health
organization they go back in they pay
500. this is very castro like it's gonna
be like two hours of just
rantings about inane things the crowd is
bored by
biden put the united states back into
the very
unfair and very costly paris climate
accord without negotiating a better deal
they wanted us so badly back in
i'll tell you they wanted us i was
getting called from all of the countries
you must come back into the paris accord
i said tell me why give me one good
reason first of all china doesn't kick
in for 10 years
russia goes by an old standard which was
not a clean standard
in other countries but we get hit right
from the beginning would have cost us
hundreds of thousands and millions of
jobs it was a disaster
but they go back in i could have made an
unbelievable deal and gone back in but i
didn't want to do that
spending millions of jobs and trillions
of dollars
to all of these other countries almost
all of them
that were in the deal so they have
favorable treatment we don't have
favorable treatment and we just
i think we're about 37 minutes in let me
see here
you could have been thirty you wanted to
go back in
which frankly we have the cleanest
stairs yeah clean this one right about
everything else that we've ever had so i
don't know why we have to
[Applause]
and what good does it do when we're
clean but china's not and russia's not
and india is not
so they're pouring fumes you know the
world is actually a small piece of the
universe
buckets of fumes pouring fumes and we're
trying to protect everything
and building products for three times
more than
is necessary no they could have made a
great deal if they were going to go back
in that's fine
but they could have made a great deal
instead of you say we're back in
these people and in one of his first
official acts
which was incredible because again he
talked about energy he never said he was
going to do this he
cancelled the keystone xl pipeline
destroying
that's great not the 8 000
or the 9 000 or the 11 000 jobs that you
hear
but 42 000 great paying jobs
on just about day one right he never
talked about that during a debate
he did well it wasn't a debate topic but
it was on his list of things he would do
not that trump knew no but that was not
a topic of conversation remember
fracking you can frack oh we love
fracking during the primary
no fracking as soon as he got through
that he said no of course everybody can
break no fracking
you wait do you see what happens with
your gasoline where do you see what
happens in
gasoline let this stuff continue you
would expect as we recover from the
virus
that gasoline prices would go up it has
nothing to do with biden or trump
pendant the united states became the
number one energy superpower on earth
number one
crowd barely cares bigger than saudi
arabia bigger than russia by a lot
we left them all in the dust they were
all in the dust
but if the democrats have their way we
are heading from
energy dominance to energy disaster
energy cuckoldry you have to see what's
going on
everything's being closed up it's a
disaster the blackouts we saw in
california last summer and
all the time and the windmill calamity
that we're witnessing in texas windmill
calamity
oh that's rich but it's so sad when you
look at
it that'll just be the start how bad is
wind power so i talk about it all the
time at cpac right we went to
cpac remember last i said we're going to
watch the president
well uh alice the wind isn't blowing i
don't believe we'll have any electricity
remember we would
we would kid but i wasn't actually
kidding it's
such an important such an expensive form
of energy here we go
so bad for the environment it kills the
birds
it destroys the land how many birds die
from fossil fuels
these are structural animals animals
there's fans on them they wear out
and when they wear out all over the
country you see them nobody takes them
down they're rotting they're rusting
how this is environmentally good for our
country and it costs
many many times more than natural gas
which is clean it costs many more to and
can
fuel our great factories how is natural
gas clean
and solar i love solar but it doesn't
have the capacity
to do what we have to do to make america
great again
that's untrue
under the radical democrat policies the
price of gasoline has already surged
30 percent since the election and we'll
go to
most of that time trump was president
seven dollars
and even higher so enjoy that when you
go to the pump and they'll say that'll
be about uh
200 to fill up your van you'll go to
this remember this used to go to the
little small
vans they got away from the big ones
that everybody wanted they went to the
small ones well
right you know what that's probably a
good investment
as long as these guys have their say you
know with the uh dvd player and the
little screens in the back of the seat
so the kids you know you don't want to
talk to the kids so you put a movie on
any bill having to do with energy our
biggest cause
we will now be relying on russia and the
middle east
for oil and they talk about russia
russia russia what's better than what
this guy's done for russia
i had oil where they were actually
paying you to take it okay
remember they were going to give you 37
a barrel but you had to take it away
you had free oil almost for a period of
time and one way i was
how much is gas these days by the way it
worked out well and i dealt with russia
and saudi arabia
and they cut back on production and we
got it
back up but now it's going the opposite
because now they're taking this
incredible energy into
250 to three dollars okay and you're
going to see costco like you have never
seen them go before
it's a very sad and very stupid thing
that they're doing
the biden policies are a massive win for
other oil producing countries and a
massive loss for the united states and
our great citizens
joe biden and the democrats are even
pushing policies that would destroy
women's sports uh-oh
here we go a lot of new records are
being
broken in women's sports hate to say
that ladies but
got a lot of new records they're being
shattered
you know for years the weightlifting
every ounce is like a big deal for many
years here we go
all of a sudden somebody comes along and
beats it by a hundred pounds
here it comes young girls and women
are in sense that they are now being
forced to compete against those who are
biological males it's not good for
women it's not good for women's sports
which worked so long and so hard to get
to where they are
the records that stood for years even
decades are now being smashed with ease
smashed
if this is not changed women's sports as
we know it
will die which trump cares about a lot
because he obviously he's been going to
wnba games for a long time he loves
women's sports
coach as an example wants to recruit a
young woman
to compete if her record can easily be
broken by somebody who
was born a man not too many of those
coaches around right
they are around they won't be around
long because they're going to have a big
problem when
their record is we're oh and 16 but
we're getting better
no i think it's crazy i think it's just
crazy what's happening
we must protect the integrity of women's
sports so important
after
standing ovation for that i'm putting
together a tweet on this
somebody said well that's going to be
very controversial i said that's okay
you haven't heard anything yet
as you can see the early weeks of the
bite trump using his delusions as a
weapon
they've been a catastrophe for american
workers and for american families
the task of our mission
and for us it's our movement as i said a
movement like has never been seen
i think we can probably say never been
seen anywhere in the world
nobody's ever seen a movement like this
i i'd grow up and
i'd watch somebody who came in second in
new hampshire
first in iowa and that was the end and
they became famous for
the rest of their lives we won the
election twice
i mean you know think about it
the task for our movement now the
crowd's ready
to stand up to this destructive agenda
with confidence and with resolve
the future of the republican party is as
a party that defends the social economic
and cultural interests and values of
working american families
of every race color and creed
that's why the party is growing so
rapidly and it's becoming
parties diminishing party and it's
becoming a party of love
record abandonment of republican voter
registration since november
the flag
amazing
this is what we're up against
there's no simple way to deprogram this
right i mean this is really a cult
ugly reality
[Applause]
now it's a party that's incredible the
people the spirit
and there as you probably heard a little
while ago i mean there's more spirit now
than there's ever been including even
before
the election more spirit now than we've
ever seen because people are seeing how
bad it can be
and again i want to thank rush and
catherine because
what he did to get the word out has been
incredible
a lot of trumpies getting banned people
are irreplaceable as sean hannity would
say and he said
rush is irreplaceable but his spirit
lives on and that's
something that we need and we love
republicans believe that the needs of
every
citizen must come first
in fact america must come first
we don't put it first they don't put it
first
over the past four years my
administration delivered for americans
of all backgrounds like never before
like never before we built the strongest
economy in the history of the world
raised wages and achieved the lowest
african-american hispanic american and
asian-american unemployment rates
ever ever ever recorded
it was so great for everybody of all
backgrounds
that even after the china virus
we are leading the world nobody's even
close we're leading it in the comeback
our economic comeback has been
incredible that's because the financial
and economic foundation we built was so
strong that unlike other countries who
are having a hard time
we didn't break we came roaring back and
now our stock market and your 401ks are
again at record levels higher than ever
before
actually those records reached under
biden but again who cares
right what is trumpism a new term being
used more and more i'm hearing that term
more and more
i didn't come up with it but what it
means is great deals great trade deals
great ones
not deals where we give away everything
our jobs our
money like the usmca replacement of the
horrible nafta nafta was
almost the same as nafta probably the
worst trade deal ever made almost
identical
we ended it you know a lot of people
forget we ended it now we have the us
mca mexico canada it's incredible what
it's done for our farmers who are doing
fantastically
did you see grain prices and grain sales
are at an
all-time high wheat all-time
high so many elements of farms and
farmers and they love me
and remember it's going to be very close
in iowa well it wasn't close we won in a
landslide iowa
because our farmers know and they put up
with it and we did a lot of work
with the tariffs and all these things
that we had to do to get it and now the
farmers are doing great
but they're setting records it means low
taxes
and eliminating job killing regulations
trumpism it means strong borders but
people coming into our country based on
a system of merit
so they come in and they can help us as
opposed to coming here
and not being good for us including no
[ __ ] countries
it means no riots in the streets it
means law
enforcement all the riots have been
under trump
under trump's presidency there's been no
riot since joe biden became president
for the second amendment and the right
to keep and bear arms
it means support for the forgotten men
and women
who have been taken advantage of for so
many years and they were doing great
they were doing great before that
horrible thing from china came in and
hit us
and now they're starting to do really
well again you know if you think about
it we built the economy twice we built
it then
and then like every other country in the
world it went down and then we built it
again now it's higher
in many ways certainly in the stock
market it's higher in many ways
than it was before that's because of the
foundation and no country
comes even close to with our comeback
and it means a strong military
and taking care of our vets but a strong
military
which we have totally rebuilt we have
rebuilt it
and our military has never been stronger
than it is today
it was tired it was depleted it was
obsolete and now we have the best brand
new equipment ever made
and it was all produced right here in
the usa isn't that nice
this is trump's militarism coming out
and we take care of our vets
you know we had a poll recently just
before leaving office
the vets had a 91 approval rating for
the way we took care of them that's the
highest number
in the history of the polls
so that's of course approval for the va
which is historically popular with vets
the question of whether military members
supported trump in 2020 they actually
supported biden
by higher numbers than they ever support
the democratic presidential candidate
the democrat parties to socialism they
want to promote
socialism ultimately leading
unfortunately to communism
and that will happen if you look at
venezuela you look at some of these
countries that's why some of our biggest
supporters
are from south america latin america
because they've seen
what goes on so that's a lie cuban
americans lean right
every other uh central and southern
south american group
are are left-wingers and of the
republican party must be to create a
future of good jobs
strong families safe communities a
vibrant culture
and a great nation for all americans and
that's what we're creating
[Applause]
their party is based upon unvarnished
disdain for america
its past and its people you see that
happening it's horrible
the way they treat the legacy of our
country the culture of our country
our party is based on love for america
and the belief that this is an
exceptional nation
blessed by god
we take great pride in our country
we teach the truth about history we
celebrate our rich heritage
and national traditions we honor george
washington
abraham lincoln thomas jefferson and all
national heroes
and of course we respect
our great american flag
will he go and hug the flag now
[Applause]
thank you thank you very much
thank you very much
[Applause]
for people wondering we're only 54
minutes in of what is expected to be
nearly a two-hour speech maybe even
longer
thank you very much
[Music]
i started that hearing we really were
we're
getting word of that hearing that during
some of the rallies especially the
latter rallies where we set
records we had 56 unbelievable packed
rallies
they set records nobody's ever had
anything like we had and we started
hearing we love you
these were the biggest rallies during a
pandemic in history like ronald reagan
right he was a great president
we had others but i said did anybody
ever say that to ronald reagan or to any
of our
great and to the best of all of these
political professionals knowledge and
pollsters nobody's ever heard that chant
before man
so it's an honor it's believe me it's an
honor
great honor it's a great honor
you know when you think about we love
you you're saying that about
i hate to say it am i a politician i
don't know
maybe i'm about i hate to i hate to
admit it
but that's really it's an honor that you
would say we believe in
patriotic education and strongly oppose
the radical indoctrination of america's
youth
it's horrible we are committed to
defending
innocent life and to upholding the
judeo-christian values of our founders
he's devoted to defending innocent life
40 percent of kova deaths under his
watch were due to poor management
we embrace free thought we stand up to
political correctness and we reject
left-wing lunacy and in particular
we reject cancer culture
right the guy scheduled to speak before
trump was
canceled because of the things he said
about jews his name is young pharaoh
we know that the rule of law is the
ultimate safeguard
and we affirm that the constitution
means
exactly what it says as
written as written
they want to change it they want to
change it they want to get rid of it
frankly
we believe in law and order and we
believe that the men and women of law
enforcement are heroes
who truly deserve our absolute
support we don't defund the police we
are not defunding
[Applause]
shutting down outsourcing bringing back
our factories and supply chains
and ensuring that america not china
dominates
the future of the world when he says
this is what
we are doing who's he talking about they
he lost the house for them in 2018
and then the senate and the white house
in 2020 like who's the we that's doing
this stuff
administration hundreds of they never
gave us 10 cents it was a one-way street
we took in hundreds of billions and
during negotiations they would say
look the one thing we don't want any
more of these tariffs these tariffs
those tariffs we took in so much money
and what happened is
they became competitive so what happened
with people they wouldn't go to china
they'd build
a lot of it back in our country they
would make it here
instead and in addition to that we would
take it in
billions and billions and billions of
dollars from china
but in all fairness to china they we
made a trade deal with them this was
prior to covet
once coveted happened i no longer cared
so much about the trade deal
because what happened with that was just
disgraceful
but that's one of the things that's one
of the reasons that right now our
farmers are doing
so good i used to celebrate look look go
and
get a lot of wheat get a lot of
different things all of the things we
just talked about
you better go out and do it because this
country
has not been treated fairly by you for
many many years
many many years we used to lose five
hundred and four
billion dollars trade deficit with john
five hundred for not millions
he still doesn't understand trade
deficits right you know that through
the world health organization now take
504 million make it 504
billion dollars we had deficits with
china it was absolutely insane that this
could
shift it's amazing that you still have a
country left the people that did this to
our country
they should be ashamed of themselves
they should be ashamed
who did it companies that leave america
to create jobs in china and other
countries that have ripped us off for
years
should not be rewarded they should be
tariffed
fined and punished they should not be
rewarded
[Music]
[Applause]
and that's what the biden administration
that's what the biden administration is
doing but of course as you know they
have a very close personal relationship
with china so i don't
i don't expect much to happen it's a
shame
because it really is a threat it's a
tremendous economic
threat and thank god we've rebuilt our
military
but it's a tremendous economic threat
never forget it these are the
convictions that define
our movement today and must define the
republican party in the years ahead very
yikes it's really quite simple isn't it
another one of the most
urgent issues facing the republican
party
is that of ensuring fair honest
and secure elections here we go
this will be the voter fraud part of the
speech
by the way a lot of people getting
banned it's sad to see what's happening
but we're going to keep using the ban
hammer as needed
such a disgrace we must pass
comprehensive election reforms
and we must do it now the democrats used
the china virus
as an excuse to change all of the
election rules without the approval of
their state legislatures
making it therefore illegal
it had a massive impact on the election
again you have to go to the legislatures
to get these approvals
this alone would have easily changed the
outcome of the election
at levels that you wouldn't have even
believed even
we don't believe it no he's right about
that with all of the things
the numbers are staggering we can never
let this
or other abuses of the 2020 election
be repeated or happen again can never
let that happen
again you see what's going on we've been
set back
so greatly with other countries and with
the world we need
election integrity and election reform
immediately republicans should be the
party of honest elections that can give
everyone confidence
in the future there is an idea without
honest elections who has confidence
who has confidence this issue is being
studied and examined
but the reality is you cannot have a
situation when i hear trump say
something is being studied
i imagine it's the same as when we hear
that anti-vaxxers have done quote
research
coming from they're coming all over the
place
where illegal aliens and dead people are
voting
and many other horrible things are
happening dead
people too voluminous even mentioned but
people know i mean it's being studied
and
the level of dishonesty is not to be
believed we have a very sick and corrupt
electoral process that must be fixed
immediately
this election was rigged and the supreme
court there it is didn't want to do
anything about it it's everyone else's
fault
he's going full in
[Music]
are they saying you won
or cuba cuba
cuba is that what they're saying
if you just take that one element where
they didn't go through legislatures it's
illegal you can't do it
it's in the constitution they didn't
have the courage the supreme court
they didn't have the courage to act but
instead used
process and lack of standing
i was told the president of the united
states has no standing it's my election
it's your election i hope he attacks
pence
we had almost 20 if you think of it
we had almost 20 states go into the
supreme court
so that we didn't have a standing
problem they rejected it
they rejected it they should be ashamed
of themselves
for what they've done to our country
they didn't have the guts or the courage
to make
the right decision they didn't want to
talk about it
you had the case led by the great state
of texas
18 states went in you don't have
standing oh let's not talk about it
they didn't have the guts to do what
should be done
wow and that's on top of all of the
other forms of cheating but this is the
most basic of all
they would have local courts and local
politicians
change the rules in some cases a day or
two before the election this should
never be allowed to happen
to another presidential candidate or
presidential race
should never be allowed to happen
today i want to outline the steps that
we must take
to have an election system in this
country that is honest
so he's just ramping up we're 64 minutes
in expected to go maybe as much as or
even more than two hours
45 30.
starting to get sweaty there
one day like it's been
and the republicans don't get this and
the other things i'm going to say that
you should like the supreme court be
ashamed of yourselves
one day one day and the only people
that should be allowed to vote by mail
are people that can be proven to be
either very sick or out of the country
or military where they can't do it
one day they have millions and millions
of ballots sitting around all over the
place
for long periods of time gee i wonder
what happens
will he say massive dumps
it's common sense it's a disgrace it's
an absolute disgrace there should be a
legitimate reason for someone
to vote absentee has to have a reason we
should eliminate the insanity of mass
and very corrupt mail-in voting
we must have voter id
voter id
you know to get into the democrat
national
convention when they had the convention
you needed voter id you needed an id
card
you couldn't get it unless you had an id
so many people told me you can't get
into that place you need id
nobody had id you need voter id they
know that
there's a con job they're counting
everybody they know that they know the
wall was good
they remember when trump said you need
id to buy cereal because we wanted i
made one big mistake on the wall
i should have said we will not
have a wall and then they would have
said let's build a wall
i made a big mistake i made a big
mistake
i'm sorry took us a year and a half
extra
because of that mistake we will not have
a wall
we need a wall immediately said chuck
schumer
we need universal signature matching
they want to pass a bill where you don't
have to match signatures where
these are the issues of paramount
importance to the country we must have
signature matching id when you need to
go into
anything that's democrat run you need it
but for voting which is our
most sacred institution
you don't they don't want to let you
have it there should be a 100
requirement to verify the citizenship of
every person who votes
you can't even register if you're not a
citizen of custody protections
for every ballot every ballot
and you saw what happened in detroit and
philadelphia
and many other places swing states
mostly
all over but swing states mostly you saw
what happened
you saw what was going on you saw that
more people
you take a look at the votes when you
have more votes and you have people
that's a problem right is that a problem
you know we have a little problem
adjusting in detroit we seem to have
more votes so we have people
a lot more votes an election changing
number we're not talking about a number
where
you can't no these are election changing
numbers
in pennsylvania they had hundreds of
thousands of
more votes than they had people voting
what's that all about
what's that all about
cheating they say yeah i'd say so
in the history of our country and it has
taken place
for years in pennsylvania and detroit
and various other places but there's
there's tremendous never like this
because they use covert
as a way of cheating right that's what
happened and everybody knows it hundreds
of thousands and millions of ballots
there's an idea
used as a way of getting what they've
wanted for many years
and the republicans have to do something
about it they better do something about
it our election process
is worse than that in many cases of a
third
world country you know that you saw what
was going on
even if you consider nothing else it is
undeniable that election rules were
illegally changed at the last minute
in almost every swing state with the
procedures
rewritten by local politicians you're
not allowed to do that
and local judges they want more time
they want this they want that all done
by local politicians
or local judges as opposed to
state legislatures as required by the
constitution of the united states is
trump even by chance saying anything
that's true
little numbers these are numbers that in
each state is
a transformative number it changes the
outcome
of the election and it's not close
regardless of your political views this
should concern
you as a constitutional matter
right and the supreme court again didn't
have the guts or the courage to do
anything about it
and neither did other judges wow
powerful speech and democrats even
admitted
in time magazine which is i would say on
the liberal side
that they couldn't they just couldn't
hold it in they had to brag about it
because what they did
they had to brag about it they couldn't
do it you got to read the story it's a
disaster
it's a disaster for our country that we
can allow something
so corrupt to happen read that article
the crowd desperate for something
interesting
yet all of the election integrity
measures in the world
will mean nothing if we don't have free
speech
and that's where we're at now if
republicans can
be censored for speaking the truth and
calling out corruption
we will not have democracy and we will
have only left-wing
tyranny and we can do this
we can do this we're smarter than they
are we're tougher than they are for some
reason we're not sure about that
we don't get it done we let them attack
our businesses and we don't attack their
businesses
i believe your numbers are bigger than
their numbers but you're nicer
they hack their business you're not as
vicious as they are more on attack yes
we would debate
i would have it i'd debate you've seen
me for many years they throw something
are you doing this again those who wins
you know people go they vote they see
what happens
but they would have an idea they would
disagree
the public would hear it the debate and
discourse would take place
and then somebody would make a decision
you would win you would lose
the public would make up its mind but
now there is no debate because they
refuse to allow our side to even speak
or be heard
they don't want debate because we have
easy victories in a debate
very easy victories it's called common
sense it's called other things but it's
called common sense
so they don't want it the time has come
to break up
big tech monopolies and restore fair
competition
it's funny that do the people in the
room even realize that it's been
republicans for 20 years who have shown
no interest in enforcing antitrust
until they think it'll get trump back on
twitter now they care about that issue
we must open up our platforms and repeal
section 230 liability
oh this again
and if the federal government refuses to
act
then every state in the union
where we have the votes which is a lot
of them big tech giants like twitter
google and facebook
should be punished with major sanctions
whenever they silence conservative
voices
not if they ban liberal people just
conservatives
and governor ron desantis of florida and
in texas
and in other states are doing this
if they do what they're doing florida
and that legislation will pass and texas
and others will have tremendous power
to do what's right and what's fair we
have no time to waste nancy pelosi
and the democrats in congress are racing
to pass
a fragrantly flagrantly unconstitutional
attack on the first amendment
super fragrant really something nasty
that he wants to be
done away with a disaster
their bill would drastically restrict
political speech
empower the federal government to shut
down descent
and turn the federal election commission
into a partisan political weapon
in addition it virtually eliminates
voter id requirements nationwide
effectively ends all registration
deadlines can you believe this requires
states
to give ballots to felons automatically
registers every welfare recipient to
vote
and puts unaccountable unelected
bureaucrats in charge of drawing
congressional districts that's going to
be a lot of fun
this monster must be stopped
it cannot be allowed to pass
now more than ever is the time for tough
strong and
energetic republican leaders who have
spines of steel we need strong
leadership
we cannot have leaders who show more
passion for condemning
their fellow americans than they have
ever shown for standing up to democrats
the media
and the radicals who want to turn
america into a socialist country
and who are they again socialists like
joe biden
who's like i guess i want a 15 minimum
wage
thanks michelle for the membership
instead of attacking me and more
importantly the voters of
our movement top establishment
republicans in washington
should be spending their energy in
opposing biden
pelosi schumer and the democrats
right i've said to some of them i said
you know
during the obama years and now during
biden
if you spent the same energy on
attacking them you'd actually be
successful
as you do on attacking me in many cases
the democrats don't have grandstanders
like mitt romney little ben
sass richard burr bill cassidy susan
collins
lisa murkowski he goes brutal attack on
republicans
beautiful hype train happening i see it
in the house
tom rice south carolina liz cheney adam
kinzinger
trump taking the republican names
anthony gonzalez that's another beauty
fred upton jamie herrera butler
peter meyer john catko david
valadeo and of course the war monger
a person that loves serious troops
fighting
liz cheney how about that
[Applause]
this is great we want them to be great
news is in her state
she's been censured and in her state her
poll numbers have dropped faster than
any human being i've ever seen
huge polls so hopefully they'll get rid
of her
with the next election get rid of them
all
democrats are vicious remember this it's
true
democrats are vicious he said evil well
there is evil there
but they're vicious they're smart and
they do one thing
you gotta hand it to them they always
stick
together you don't have mitt romney's in
the group they always stick together
fortunately
for the republican party the democrats
have
horrible policies like open borders
sanctuary cities defunding the police
and the ridiculous totally ridiculous
green new deal
so they stick together they're smart
their vision he seems to be really out
of control right now
their policies are no good so hence we
have congratulations
the republican party
i actually think in a sense that the
left is more divided but i think they
don't miss the forest for the trees when
it comes to voting mostly
now their policies are horrible think of
it defund the police
how did that work out but if republicans
nobody did it
not stick together the rhinos
that we're surrounded with will destroy
surrounded by rhinos
and will destroy our country itself the
rhinos you know republican in name only
but the republican party is united the
only division is between a handful of
washington d.c establishment political
hacks and
everybody else all over the country i
think we have tremendous unity when you
look at the crowds outside
that want your seat so badly they will
take your seat
in two seconds they want your seat
congratulations congratulations on
getting in by the way i'm very
proud
and that's why i'm announcing that i
will be actively working to elect
strong tough and smart republican leader
there it is he says he's not going away
the hype train continues on twitch
[Applause]
so
speaking of that i heard jim jordan did
a great job right
uh-oh i heard that from mark meadows a
great job at what
oh there he is look at that hi jim i
heard you were great in fact i hated to
follow you
i want to follow other people i could
name them too
i like to follow other people i heard
you were great thank you jim very much
jim jordan a great great athlete
people don't know he was a great great
wrestler wrestler
tremendous numbers of victories the nc
he was a champion amazing wrestler
champion
for a long period of time he's a winner
and a leader and
he doesn't play games he likes to win
how much abuse did he ignore
and we have a lot of people in our party
that like to win jim right but i heard
you were great thank you very much
but we want republican leaders who are
loyal to the voters and who will work
proudly for the vision
that i've laid out today and what is it
so simple
right so simple military law and order
great trade deals
great education so simple i don't
does anybody get it what are they doing
does anybody get it it has just been
stated
that president trump's endorsement is
the most powerful asset in politics you
believe
who would have thought that's going
gonna happen jim as a torpedo rather
than a hot air balloon
congressional primaries 120
listen to this it's crazy 120 of 122
candidates i endorsed
one 120 that's almost as good as jim's
wrestling record
the two that lost were beaten by people
claiming to be
more trump than their opponent so i like
those two people very much also
in the senate i was undefeated in
endorsements with a record of 21-0
what about georgia endorsement of mitch
mcconnell wait wait wait what about
georgia
[Applause]
john is now he made a request he asked
for my endorsement
brought him from one point down to 20
points up
and he won his race in the great state
and
actually the great commonwealth of
kentucky
and he won it and he won it very easily
and i said i wonder if i'm doing the
right thing here but you know what
i did i did what i did but he went from
what about the two georgia ones
two 20 points up very quickly
immediately actually
and he won this race and if you compare
that to his other elections
uh i'm sure you see something
interesting but you know what we got a
republican elected
and now we have to use republicans to
take care of the election frauds and all
of the other things
that are happening that shouldn't be
allowed to happen in our country it's
like he lost the roy moore thing in 2017
or wherever it was
he lost both georgia what's he talking
about 21-0
and i helped keep many senators in their
seats and they will admit it
so that it's now 50-50 instead of
republicans being down
anywhere from eight to ten seats and
they'll admit it
we take an allergy if i didn't campaign
we held rallies for some of the
senators that were down and nobody talks
about that
nobody wants to talk to pressless and
talk about it with me at the top of the
ticket not a single
republican member of congress lost their
race for the first time in decades
we won 26 of 26 toss-up races
think of that 26 of 20 and those are
toss-up those are races that could go
anywhere
we were expected to lose 25 seats
and instead we won 15 seats and almost
oh why couldn't we have done a couple of
more almost caused crazy nancy her job
we'll do that it's crazy how much
victory he's claiming given that he lost
the house for republicans in 2018
lost himself as well as losing the
senate for for republicans in 2020.
almost 1.5 million more votes than
all of the republican house candidates
combined
so how the hell is it possible that we
lost it's not possible
right i got more votes i got more
which is me when i say i i'm talking
about we we
we got more votes than any incumbent
any incumbent president in the history
of our country almost 75 million votes
right but not as many as joe biden and
that doesn't
include the votes and ballots they threw
out okay
if you include them you'll see numbers
that are much different we did even
better in the second election than we
did in the first you know i won the
first
and we won the second we how is it
better to lose sort of strange right
how did you do well we did much better
the second time oh you did really
what a disgrace what a disgrace to our
country
i got over 11 million very close to 12
million more votes than we got in 2016
and i was told by
john mclaughlin that if you the great
pollster
that if you get to see we had 63 in
2016.
63 million sir if you get to 66 million
you have it made we got to almost 75
million then
what the hell happened the pollster was
wrong
for how much trump talks about how
terrible posters are now he's saying a
pollster told me something and they
weren't right
302 in the morning what happened
no president has ever lost an election
after carrying florida ohio
and iowa another first i won them by a
lot
by a lot i won 94
of the primary vote no incumbent
president who received more than 75
percent
of the primary vote has ever lost an
election
there was no challenge today and no
president has ever ever and we're
talking about a
much lower number than we got has ever
lost an election
thanks to my coattails you guys
following this
we have to have a sense of humor thanks
to my coattails democrats failed to flip
a single state legislature think of it
or a legislative chamber because
republicans
came out to vote for me now they say it
differently the press the fake news
spends it differently
i don't know what he's talking about
despite how well they did
trump didn't win that's such a lie
and many legislatures you know many
legislators told me they said
they're going to lose their race it
wasn't going to happen and then what
happened is one in particular told me
from a
great swing state said you know i
thought i was going to lose my position
lose my race and i went out with my wife
the night before the election and i saw
all these trump signs and the american
flags and the spirits on the streets i
said you know darling i think we're
going to win
right he said but you were far far far
more popular than me they do lots of
polls you were way way ahead of me sir
and the next day i was right he said he
won the election by a lot
and you lost the election and sir it's
not possible that you lost
because you got a lower number than i
did and you were so far ahead of me
you're the person sir you got a lower
number from the standpoint of positive
and then it was low but it went high and
then a pollster john mclaughlin told me
this and so we won everything don't you
guys get it
and i've heard it from more than one
and in november 18 of 19 bellwether
counties you heard about the bellwether
counties
18 of 19 bellwether counties that have
correctly predicted
every presidential elected election for
decades many decades
voted for trump not for
biden and it was a shocker to those
people that go
for the the stats it was a shocker
the stats people trump 18 of 19 voted
for trump there's never been anything
like that
and yet did biden win no this is making
his loss
even more humiliating is the takeaway
i'm getting go to donald j
trump.com i don't do this i've never
done this but
it's time that we have put forces
together because he's fine
what's he doing and they're fake news
media right is he raising money
okay and you know when you talk about
election they turn off
when you talk about they probably have
them going because they also care about
readings but
when they talk about elections it's
terrible what he's doing please sign up
at joinpakman.com what a humiliation
what trump is doing right here
they don't like that subject there's
only one way to contribute
to our efforts to elect america first
republican conservatives and in turn to
make america great again and that's
through
save america pac and donald j trump.com
so go out there and do whatever you can
because we're going to help a lot of
great people we know the right people to
help we need your help to win
and to fight big tech and the radical
left and the dc establishment
we need to save your second amendment
which is under siege
it's fine i need to help the second
amendment's fine military and for our
great vets
and that's what we're doing as we
discussed
earlier trump pumping toon toon stock
survival of america
as we know it this is a struggle this is
a
terrible terrible painful struggle the
path ahead will not be easy but we will
win we are going to win
ultimately we always win
and when we do history will show that
this was the moment
people heading for the exit when we
could have
despaired but instead we chose to keep
on pushing forward
the greater the challenge and tougher
the task the more determined we must be
to pull through to triumph
we have to have triumph we have to have
victory with the talent and dedication
of everyone here today and you have
tremendous
not only dedication so who thinks there
will be ymca
after who thinks there will not i'm not
going to play it so if we hear it it'll
be legit
we will go on to victory we will summon
the spirit of generations of american
patriots before
us like those heroes who crossed the
delaware
conquered the rockies stormed the
beaches won the battles and tamed the
unknown frontiers
we will persist and we will prevail
we're tougher than they are
we're stronger than they are
together in the coming years we will
carry forward the torch of american
liberty
we will lead the conservative movement
and the republican party
back to a totally conclusive victory and
we've had tremendous victories don't
ever forget it
with your help we will take back the
house
we will win the senate and then
a republican president will make a
triumphant
return to the white house and i wonder
who that will be
with your help we'll win back all of the
things i lost for you over the last two
years
by doing the exact same thing somehow
who who who will that be i wonder
standing before you today i am supremely
confident
that for our movement for our party
and for our country our brightest days
are just ahead and that together we will
make america prouder
freer stronger and greater than it ever
has been before thank you cpac
god bless you and god bless america
thank you all
thank you there it is
whoever took the yes on ymca coming out
ahead
what if what a bizarre delusional speech
will he dance i guess is the next
question
[Music]
a strange speech meandering at times
the stuff of nightmares
[Music]
absolutely no connection to reality
it looks like he will exit with no
dancing just the fist pump
just kind of wandering off stage uh
man
what an embarrassment
the audio problems continue to plague
cpac
certainly conceivable antifa
was able to take over the audio systems
and make it sound
terrible like a school assembly
looks like now the dance party will be
starting man what a what an event
i was actually um hold on let me turn
this down for us
i was starting to prepare my remarks
tomorrow for tomorrow's show about cpac
and i i was making a comparison to a
comic-con but i realized you know
at comic-con i don't want to make fun of
comic-con at comic-con you would have
interesting sci-fi writers and people
who conceive of
you know various programs that would
have interesting things to say
and i think there's much more of value
actually at a comic-con than
i've never been to one but i don't want
to denigrate comic-con in order to make
a joke so i'll make that
clarification tomorrow
dear god look at this
what has happened to this country
maggot cowboy hat guy really loving the
village people
a lot of bowl cuts i'm noticing i
thought i didn't know the the bowl cut i
thought was out
yeah the irony of all of this stuff
this is like the time at a wedding where
it's sort of like
it's kind of over but they've still got
the room for 30 more minutes
okay and then it is over all right very
good okay uh thanks everybody that is
donald trump i appreciate
everybody joining me um in all
seriousness i can't thank you enough i
do want to say thanks to jennifer faison
who just signed up on my website and
that's a beautiful thing
make sure to subscribe free on youtube
make sure that you are
following on twitch let's raid somebody
on twitch
hoo hoo hoo let's raid
oh nobody nobody's really oh let's raid
anna rudolph
uh we have way more people than she has
watching right now
she's been a friend to the show i think
she will very much appreciate several
thousand people coming in
so we will raid on a rudolph on twitch i
hope you will come with me
and we'll be back this week uh with so
much more
all right thanks everybody very very
exciting stuff
if there is anything uh satirized and
remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way
extra points if you can sample trump
saying massive dumps and me talking
about it in a song
please do it